the following is a conversation with jim
keller his second time in the podcast
jim is a legendary microprocessor
architect
and is widely seen as one of the
greatest engineering minds
of the computing age in a peculiar twist
of space-time in our simulation jim is
also
a brother-in-law of jordan peterson we
talk about this
and about computing artificial
intelligence
consciousness and life quick mention of
our sponsors
athletic greens all-in-one nutrition
drink brooklyn and sheetz
expressvpn and belcampo grass-fed
meat click the sponsor links to get a
discount and to support this podcast as
a side note let me say that jim is
someone who on a personal level
inspired me to be myself there was
something in his words
on and off the mic or perhaps that he
even paid attention to me at all
that almost told me you're all right kid
a kind of pat on the back that can
make the difference between a mind that
flourishes and a mind that is broken
down
by the cynicism of the world so i guess
that's just my brief few words of thank
you to jim and in general
gratitude for the people who have given
me a chance on this podcast
in my work and in life if you enjoy this
thing
subscribe on youtube review on apple
podcast follow on spotify
support on patreon or connect with me on
twitter alex friedman
and now here's my conversation with jim
keller what's the value and
effectiveness of theory versus
engineering
this dichotomy in uh building good
software
or hardware systems well it's
good designs both i guess that's pretty
obvious
but engineering do you mean you know
reduction of practice of known methods
and then science is the pursuit of
discovering things that people don't
understand
or solving unknown problems definitions
are interesting here but
i was thinking more in theory
constructing models
that kind of generalize about how things
work and engineering
is like actually building stuff the
pragmatic like
okay we have these nice models but how
do we actually get things to work maybe
economics is a nice example like
economists have all these models of how
the economy works and
how different policies will have an
effect but then there's the actual
okay let's call it engineering of like
actually deploying the policies
so computer design is almost all
engineering
and reduction of practice is known
message now
because of the complexity of the
computers we built
you know you could think you're well
we'll just go write some code
and then we'll verify it and we'll put
it together and then you find out that
the combination of all that stuff is
complicated
and then you have to be inventive to
figure out how to do it
right so that's that's definitely
happens a lot
and then every so often some big idea
happens
but it might be one person and that idea
is in what
in the space of engineering or is it in
the space well i'll give you an example
so one of the limits of computer
performance is branch predictions
so and there's there's a whole bunch of
ideas about how good you could predict
the branch
and people said there's a limit to it
it's an asthmatic curve
and somebody came up with a better way
to do branch prediction it was a lot
better
and he published a paper on it and every
computer in the world now uses it
and it was one idea so the the engineers
who build branch prediction hardware
were happy to drop the one kind of
training array and put it in another one
so it was it was a real idea and branch
prediction is
is one of the key problems underlying
all of sort of the lowest level of
software it boils down to branch
prediction
boils down to uncertainty computers are
limited by you know single thread
computers limited by two things
the predictability of the path of the
branches and the predictability of the
locality
of data so we have predictors that now
predict both of those pretty well
yeah so memory is you know a couple
hundred cycles away local cache is
couple cycles away
when you're executing fast virtually all
the data has to be in the local cache
so a simple program says you know add
one to every element in array
it's really easy to see what the stream
of data will be
but you might have a more complicated
program that you know says get a get an
element of this array look at something
make a decision
go get another element it's kind of
random and you can think that's really
unpredictable
and then you make this big predictor
that looks at this kind of pattern and
you realize
well if you get this data in this data
then you probably want that one
and if you get this one and this one and
this one you probably want that one
and is that theory or is that
engineering like the paper that was
written
was it uh well it was asymptotic kind of
kind of discussion or is it more like
here's a hack that works well
um it's a little bit of both like
there's information theory in it i think
somewhere
okay so that's actually trying to prove
yeah but once once you know the method
implementing it is an engineering
problem
now there's a flip side of this which is
in a big design team
what percentage of people think their
their
their uh their their plan or their
life's work is engineering versus design
inventing things so lots of companies
will reward you for
filing patents yes some many big
companies get stuck because to get
promoted you have to come up with
something new
and then what happens is everybody's
trying to do some random new thing
99 which doesn't matter and the basics
get
neglected and or
they get to there's a dichotomy they
think like the cell library and the
basic cad tools
you know or basic you know software
validation methods
that's simple stuff you know they want
to work on the exciting stuff
and then they they spend lots of time
trying to figure out how to patent
something
and that's mostly useless but the
breakthroughs are on the simple stuff
no no you no you have to do the simple
stuff really well
if you're brilliant building a building
out of bricks you want great bricks
so you go to two places to sell bricks
so one guy says yeah they're over there
in an
ugly pile and the other guy is like
lovingly tells you about the 50 kinds of
bricks and how hard they are and how
beautiful they are and
how square they are and you know which
one you can buy bricks from
which is going to make a better house so
you're talking about the craftsman the
person who understands bricks who loves
bricks who loves their varieties
that's a good word you know good
engineering is great craftsmanship
and when you start thinking engineering
is about invention
and set up a system that rewards
invention
the craftsmanship gets neglected okay so
maybe one perspective is the theory the
science
over emphasizes invention and
engineering emphasizes craftsmanship and
therefore
like so if you it doesn't matter what
you do in theory well everybody knows
like read the tech rags they're always
talking about some breakthrough or
intervention
innovation and everybody thinks that's
the most important thing
but the number of innovative ideas is
actually relatively low we need them
right and innovation creates a whole new
opportunity like when
when some guy invented the internet
right
like that was a big thing the million
people that wrote software against that
were mostly doing
engineering software writing so the
elaboration of that idea was huge
i don't know if you know brendan ike he
wrote javascript in 10 days
and that's an interesting story it makes
me wonder
and it was you know famously for many
years considered to be
a pretty crappy programming language
still is perhaps it's been improving
sort of consistently
but the interesting thing about that guy
is
you know he doesn't get any awards you
don't get a nobel prize or a field medal
or
uh a crappy piece of
you know that software code that is
currently the number one programming
language in the world that runs
now is cons increasingly running the
backhand of the internet what does he
end up does he know why everybody uses
it
like that would be an interesting thing
was it the right thing at the right time
because like when stuff like javascript
came out like there's a move from you
know writing c programs and c
plus plus to let's call what they call
managed code frameworks
where you write simple code it might be
interpreted it has
lots of libraries productivity is high
and you don't have to be an expert
so you know java was supposed to solve
all the world's problems it
was complicated javascript came out you
know after a bunch of other scripting
languages
i'm not an expert on it but yeah but was
it the right thing at the right time
or was there something you know clever
because he wasn't the only one
there's a few elements maybe if he
figured out what it was
no then he'd get a prize like that
destructive theory
yeah you know babies probably he hasn't
defined this
or he this needs a good promoter well
i think there was a bunch of blog posts
written about it which is like
wrong is right which is like doing the
crappy thing fast
just like hacking together the thing
that answers some of the needs
and then iterating over time listening
to developers like listening to people
who actually use the thing
this is something you can do more in
software
but the right time like you have to
sense you have to have a good
instinct of when is the right time for
the right tool and make it super
simple and just get it
out there the problem is this is true
with hardware this is less true with
software is
this backward compatibility that just
drags behind you as
you know as you try to fix all the
mistakes of the past but the the timing
was good there's something about that it
wasn't accidental
you have to like give yourself over to
the
you have to have this like broad sense
of what's needed now
and both scientifically and like the
community
and just like this it was obvious that
uh
there was no the interesting thing about
javascript is
everything that ran in the browser at
the time like java
and and i think other like scheme other
programming languages
they were all in a separate external
container
and then javascript was literally just
injected into the web page it was the
dumbest possible thing
running in the same thread as everything
else and like
uh it was inserted as a comment so
javascript code is inserted as a comment
in the html code and it was i mean it's
there's it's either genius or super dumb
but it's like
right so it has no apparatus for like a
virtual machine and container
it just executed in the framework the
program is already running
and it was that's cool and then uh
because something about that
accessibility
the ease of its use uh
resulted in then developers innovating
on how to actually use it
i mean i don't even know what to make of
that but
it does seem to echo across different
software
like stories of different software php
has the same story really crappy
language
they just took over the world i always
have a joke that
the random length instructions that
variable length instructions that's
always one
even though they're obviously worse like
nobody knows why
x86 is arguably the worst architecture
you know on the planet is one of the
most popular ones well i mean isn't
isn't that also the story of risk versus
i mean is that simplicity there's
something about simplicity that
uh us in this evolutionary process
is valued if it's simple it's uh
gets it spreads faster it seems like
yeah or is that not always true
that's always true yeah it could be
simple is good but too simple is bad
so why did risk win you think so far did
risk win
in the long arc of history maybe we
don't know so who who's going to win
what what's risk what's cisco who's
going to win in that space
in these instruction sets a ice offers
going to win but
they'll be little computers that run
little programs like normal
all over the place but but
we're we're going through another
transformation so but
you think instruction sets underneath it
all will change
yeah they evolve slowly they don't
matter very much
they don't matter very much okay i mean
the limits of performance are
you know predictability of instructions
and data i mean that's the big thing
and then the usability of it is some you
know
quality of design quality of tools
availability
like right now x86 is proprietary with
intel and amd but they can change it any
way they want independently
right arm is proprietary to arm and they
won't let anybody else change it
so it's like a sole point and risk 5 is
open source
so anybody can change it which is super
cool
but that also might mean it gets changed
in too many random ways that there's no
common
sub subset of it that people can use do
you like open
or do you like clothes like if you were
to bet all your money on one or the
other risk five versus
no idea it's case dependent well x86
oddly enough when intel first started
developing it they licensed
like seven people so it was the open
architecture
and then they move faster than others
and also bought one or two of them
but there were seven different people
making x86 because at the time there was
6502 and z80s and you know 8086
and you could argue everybody thought
z80 was the better instruction set
but that was propriety proprietary to
one place
oh and the 6800 so there's like five or
four or five different microprocessors
intel went open got the market share
because people felt like they had
multiple sources from it and then over
time it narrowed down the two players
so why you as a historian uh well
why did intel win for so long
with the with their processors i mean
they were great their process
development was great
oh so it's just looking back to
javascript and brand nike is uh
microsoft and netscape and all these uh
internet browsers
microsoft won the browser game because
they aggressively stole
other people's ideas like right after
they did it
you know i i don't know if intel was
stealing other people's ideas
they started making a just good way they
started making
rams random access memories
and then at the time when the japanese
manufacturers came up
you know they were getting out competed
on that and they pivoted the
microprocessors and they made the first
you know integrated microprocessor
programs uh 4004 or something
who was behind that pivot that's a hell
of a pivot andy grove
and he was great that's a hell of a
pivot
and then they led semiconductor industry
like they were just a little company ibm
all kinds of big companies had
both loads of money and they out
innovated everybody
auto innovated okay yeah yeah so it's
not like marketing it's not yeah
their processor designs were pretty good
um
i think the you know core 2
was probably the first one i thought was
great
it was a really fast processor and then
haswell was great
what makes a great processor in that
delay oh if you just look at it's
performance versus everybody else
it's you know the size of it the you
know usability of it
so it's not specific some kind of
element that makes it beautiful it's
just like literally just raw
performance is that how you think about
processors it's just like
raw performance of course
it's like a horse race the fastest one
wins
now you don't care how
[Laughter]
just as long as it was well there's the
fastest in the environment
like right you know for years you made
the fastest one you could and then
people started to have power limits
so then you made the fastest at the
right power point and then
and then when we started doing
multiprocessors like
if you could scale your processors more
than the other guy you could be 10
faster on like a single thread but you
have more threads
so there's lots of variability and then
arm
really explored like you know they have
the a series and the r
series and the m series like a family of
processors for all these different
design points from like unbelievably
small and simple
and so then when you're doing the design
it's sort of like this big palette of
cpus
like they're the only ones with a
credible you know top to bottom palette
and what do you mean incredible
top to bottom well there's people who
make microcontrollers that are small but
they don't have a fast one there's
people make fast processors but don't
have a little a medium one or a small
one is it hard to do that full palette
that's
that seems like a it's a lot of
different so what's the difference in
uh the arm folks and intel in terms of
the way they're approaching this problem
well intel almost all their processor
designs were
you know very custom high end you know
for the last 15
20 years the fastest force possible yeah
in one horseshoe
yeah and then architecture they're
really good but the company itself was
fairly insular to what's going on in the
industry with cad tools and stuff
and there's this debate about custom
design versus synthesis
and how do you approach that i'd say
intel was slow on the
getting to synthesize processors arm
came in from the bottom and they
generated ip which went to all kinds of
customers
so they had very little say how the
customer implemented their
ip so arm is super friendly to the
synthesis ip environment whereas intel
said we're going to make this great
client chip server chip with our own cad
tools with our own process with our own
you know other supporting ip and
everything only works with our stuff
so is that is arm winning the mobile
platform space in terms of processors
and so
in that and what you're describing is
why they're winning well they
had lots of people doing lots of
different experiments so they controlled
the processor architecture and ip
but they let people put in lots of
different chips and there was a lot of
variability in what happened there
whereas intel when they made their
mobile their foray into mobile they had
one team doing one
part right so it wasn't 10 experiments
and then their mindset was pc mindset
microsoft software mindset and that
brought a whole bunch of things along
that
the mobile world embedded world don't do
do you think it was possible for intel
to pivot hard and win the mobile
market that's a hell of a difficult
thing to do right for a huge company to
just pivot
i mean it's so interesting to because
we'll talk about your current work
it's like it's clear that pcs were
dominating for several decades
like desktop computers and then mobile
it's unclear it's a leadership question
like like apple under steve jobs when he
came back they pivoted multiple
times you know they built ipads and
itunes and phones and tablets and
great macs like like who knew computers
should be made out of aluminum
nobody knew that that they're great it's
super fun that was steve yeah steve jobs
like they pivoted multiple times
and uh you know the old intel they they
did that multiple times
they made drams and processors and
processes and
i got to ask this what was it like
working with steve jobs i didn't work
with him
did you interact with him twice i said
hi to him twice in the cafeteria
what did he say hi he said hey fellas
he was friendly he was wandering around
and
with somebody he couldn't find the table
because the cafeteria was
was packed and i gave my table but i
worked for mike colbert who talked to
like mike was the unofficial cto of
apple
and a brilliant guy and he worked for
steve for 25 years maybe more
and he talked to steve multiple times a
day
and he was one of the people who could
put up with steve's let's say brilliance
and intensity
and and steve really liked him and steve
trusted
mike to translate the [ __ ] he thought up
into engineering products at work and
then mike ran a group called platform
architecture and i was in that group
so many times i'd be sitting with mike
and the phone would ring
it'd be steve and mike would hold the
phone like this because steve would be
yelling about something or other
yeah and he would translate it and he
translated and then he would say
steve wants us to do this so
was steve a good engineer or no i don't
know he was a great idea guy
idea person he's a really good selector
for talent
yeah so that seems to be one of the key
elements of leadership right
and then he was a really good first
principals guy like like somebody say
something couldn't be done and he would
just think
that's obviously wrong right
but you know maybe it's hard to do maybe
it's expensive to do maybe we need
different people
you know there's like a whole bunch of
you know if you want to do something
hard
you know maybe it takes time maybe you
have to iterate there's a whole bunch of
things
you could think about but saying it
can't be done is stupid
how would you compare so it seems like
elon musk is more
engineering centric but it's also i
think he considers himself a designer
too he has a design mind
steve jobs feels like he is much more
idea space design space versus
engineering yeah just make it happen
like the world should be this way just
figure it out but
but he used computers you know he had
computer people talk to him all the time
like mike was a really good computer guy
he knew what computers could do
computer meaning computer hardware like
hardware software all of pieces the
whole thing
and then he would you know have an idea
about what could we do with this next
that was grounded in reality it wasn't
like he was you know just
finger painting on the wall and wishing
somebody would interpret it
like so he had this interesting
connection because
no he wasn't a computer architect or a
designer
but he had an intuition from the
computers we had to what could happen
and essentially you say intuition
because
it seems like he was pissing off a lot
of engineers in
his intuition about what canada can't be
done those
like the what is all these stories about
like floppy disks and all that kind of
stuff like
yeah so in in steve the first round like
he'd go into a lab
and look at what's going on and hate it
and and
uh fire people or or ask somebody in the
elevator what they're doing for apple
and you know not be happy when he came
back my impression was
is he surrounded himself with this
relatively small group of people
yes and didn't really interact outside
of that as much
and then the joke was you'd see like
somebody moving a prototype through the
quad with a
with a black blanket over it and that
was because it was secret
you know partly from steve because they
didn't want steve to see it until it was
ready
yeah the dynamic with johnny ive and
steve
is interesting it's like you don't wanna
he ruins as many ideas as he generates
yeah
yeah it's a dangerous kind of line to
walk
if you have a lot of ideas like like
gordon bell was famous for ideas
right and it wasn't that the percentage
of good ideas was way higher than
anybody else
it was he had so many ideas and and he
was also good at talking people about it
and
and getting the filters right and you
know seeing through stuff
whereas elon was like hey i want to
build rockets so
steve would hire a bunch of rocket guys
and elon would go read rocket manuals
so ian is a better engineer a sense like
or like more uh
like a love and passion for the manuals
yeah
and the details the details the
craftsmanship too right
well i guess you had craftsmanship too
but of a different kind
what do you make of the just the
standard for just a little longer what
do you make of like the anger and the
passion and all that the the firing and
the
mood swings and the madness the
um you know being emotional and all that
that's
steve and i i guess elon too so what is
that a is that a bugger feature
it's a feature so there's a graph which
is
uh y-axis productivity yeah x-axis at
zero it's chaos
yeah and infinity is complete order yeah
right so as you go from the
you know the origin as you improve order
you improve productivity
yeah and at some point productivity
peaks and then it goes back down again
yeah too much order nothing can happen
yes but the question is
is how close to the chaos is that no no
no here's the thing
is once you start moving the directional
order the force vector to drive you
towards order is unstoppable
oh this is the same every organization
will
move to the place where their
productivity is stymied by order
so you need uh so the question is who's
the counter force
like because it also feels really good
as you get more organized
then productivity goes up the
organization feels it they orient it
towards it right to hire more people
they get more guys who can run process
you get bigger
right and then inevitably inevitably
the organization gets captured by the
bureaucracy that manages all the
processes
right and then humans really like that
and so if you just walk into a room
and say guys love what you're doing
but i need you to have less order
if you don't have some force behind that
nothing will happen
i i can't tell you on how many levels
that's profound so
so that's why i'd say it's a feature now
could you be nicer about it
i don't know i don't know any good
examples of being nicer about it
well the funny thing is to get stuff
done you need people who can manage
stuff and manage people because humans
are complicated they need lots of care
and feeding and you need to tell them
they look nice and they're doing good
stuff and pat them on the back
right i don't know do you tell me is
that is that needed
humans need that i had a friend he
started to manage the group and he said
i figured it out you have to praise them
before they do anything
i was waiting until they were done and
they're always mad at me
now i tell them what a great job they're
doing while they're doing it but then
you get stuck in that trap because then
when they're not doing something how do
you confront these people
i think a lot of people that had trauma
in their childhood who disagree with you
successful people
that you just first do the rough stuff
and then be nice later
i don't know okay but you know nice
engineering companies are full of adults
who had all kinds of range of childhoods
you know most people had okay childhoods
well i don't know if uh and lots of
people only work for praise
which is weird you mean like everybody
i'm not that interested in this but uh
well you
you're you're probably looking for
somebody's approval um
even still yeah maybe i should think
about that
maybe somebody who's no longer with this
kind of thing
i don't know i used to call it my dad
and tell him what i was doing he was he
was very excited about engineering and
stuff
you got his approval uh yeah a lot
i was lucky like he he decided i was
smart and unusual as a kid and that was
okay when i was really young
so when i like did poorly in school i
was dyslexic i didn't read until i was
third or fourth grade and they didn't
care my parents were like
oh he'll be fine so
that was funny that was cool is he still
with us
you miss him sure yeah he had
parkinson's and then cancer his last 10
years were tough
and i killed him killing a man like
that's hard
the mind well it's pretty good um
parkinson's causes slow dementia and uh
the chemotherapy i think accelerated it
but it was like hallucinogenic dementia
so he was
clever and funny and interesting and
was it was pretty unusual do you
remember conversations
uh of course from that time like where
do you have fond memories
of the guy yeah oh yeah anything come to
mind
a friend told me one time i could draw a
computer on the whiteboard faster than
anybody you'd ever met
and i said you should meet my dad like
when i was a kid he'd come home and say
i was driving by this bridge and i was
thinking about it and he pulled out a
piece of paper and he'd draw the whole
bridge
he was a mechanical engineer yeah and he
would just draw the whole thing and then
he would tell me about it and
tell me how you would have changed it
and he had this you know
idea that he could understand and
conceive anything and i i just grew up
with that so that was natural
so if you know like when i interview
people i ask them to draw a picture of
something they did on a whiteboard
and it's really interesting like some
people draw a little box
you know and then they'll say and then
this talks to this and yeah
i'd be like this is frustrating and i
had this other guy come in one time he
says
well i designed a floating point in this
chip but i'd really like to tell you how
the whole thing works and then tell you
how the floating point works inside of
it do you mind if i do that
he covered two whiteboards yeah like 30
minutes and i hired him
like yeah he was great this is craftsman
i mean that's the craftsmanship to that
yeah but also the the mental agility to
understand the whole thing
right put the pieces in contacts like
you know
real view of the balance of how the
design worked
because if you don't understand it
properly when you start to draw it
you'll fill up half the white board with
like a little piece of it and
you know like your ability to lay it out
in an understandable way it takes a lot
of understanding so
and be able to zoom into the detail and
then zoom out to the zoom
really fast what about the impossible
thing you see your dad
believed that uh you could do anything
that's a weird feature for a craftsman
yeah
it seems that that uh echoes in your own
behavior
like that's that's the well it's not
that anybody can do anything right now
right it's that if you work at it you
can get better at it
and there might not be a limit
and they did funny things like like he
always wanted to play piano so at the
end of his life he started playing the
piano
when he had parkinson's and he was
terrible
but he thought if he really worked out
in this life maybe the next life he'd be
better at it
he might be onto something yeah
he enjoyed doing it yeah so that's
pretty funny do you think the
perfect is the enemy of the good in
hardware and software engineering
it's like we were talking about
javascript a little bit and
the messiness of the 10-day building
process
yeah it's you know creative tension
right
the creative tension is you have two
different ideas that you can't do both
right right and then but the fact that
you want to do both
causes you to go try to solve that
problem that's the creative part
so if you're building computers like
some people say we have the schedule
and anything that doesn't fit in the
schedule we can't do
right so they throw out the perfect
because they have a schedule
i hate that then there's other people
who say we need to get this perfectly
right
and no matter what you know more people
more money
right and there's a really clear idea
about what you want some people are
going to articulate in it
right so let's call that the perfect
yeah yeah
all right but that's also terrible
because they never ship anything you
never hit any goals
so now you have that now you have your
framework yes you can't throw out stuff
because you can't get it done today
because maybe you get it done tomorrow
or the next project
right you can't so you have to i work
with a guy that i really like working
with
but he over filters his ideas over
filters
he'd start thinking about something and
as soon as he figure out what's wrong
with it you'd throw it out
and then i start thinking about it like
you know you come up with an idea and
then you find out what's wrong with it
and then you give it a little time to
set because sometimes you know you
figure out
how to tweak it or maybe that idea helps
some other idea
so idea generation is really funny so
you have to give your ideas space
like spaciousness of mind is key but you
also have to execute programs and get
[ __ ] done
and then it turns out computer
engineering is fun because it takes you
know 100 people to build a computer
200 to 300 whatever the number is and
people are so
variable about you know temperament and
you know skill sets and stuff
that you know in a big organization you
find that the people who love the
perfect ideas and the people that want
to get stuff done yesterday and
people like to come up with ideas and
people like to
let's say shoot down ideas and it takes
the whole
it takes a large group of people some
are good at generating ideas some are
good at filtering ideas and then
all in that giant mess you somehow
i guess the goal is for that giant mess
of people to uh
find the perfect path through the
attention the creative tension
but like how do you know when you said
there's some people good at articulating
what perfect looks like what a good
design is like if you're sitting in a
in a room and uh you have a set of ideas
about like how to design uh a better
processor how do you know
this is this is something special here
this is a good idea
let's try this so have you ever
brainstormed idea with a couple people
that were really smart
and you kind of go into it and you you
don't quite understand it
and you're working on it and then you
start you know
talking about it putting it on the
whiteboard
maybe it takes days or weeks and then
your brain start to kind of synchronize
it's really weird and like you start to
see what each other is thinking
and yeah and it starts to work like you
can see work like my talent in computer
design is i can
i can see how computers work in my head
like really well
and i know other people can do that too
and when you're working with people that
can do that
like it is kind of a an amazing
experience
and then and every once in a while you
get to that place and then you find the
flaw
which is kind of funny because you you
can you can fool yourself in
but the two of you kind of drifted along
yeah
into the direction that was useless yeah
that happens too like you have to
because you know well the nice thing
about computer design there's always
reduction in practice
like you come up with your good ideas
and i know some architects who really
love ideas
and then they work on them and they put
it on the shelf they go work on the next
idea and put on the shelf they never
reduce the practice
so they find out what's good and bad
because most
every time i've done something really
new by the time it's done
like the good parts are good but i know
all the flaws like
yeah would you say your career just your
own experience
is your career defined by mostly by
flaws or by successes
like if again there's great tension
between those if you haven't
tried hard yeah right and done something
new
right then you're not going to be facing
the challenges when you build it then
you find out all the problems with it
and but when you look back you see
problems
okay oh when i look back um what do you
think earlier in my career
yeah like eb5 was the second alpha chip
uh i was so embarrassed about the
mistake so i could barely talk about it
and it was in the guinness book of
worlds records and it was the fastest
processor on the planet
yeah so it was and at some point i
realized that was really a bad
mental framework to deal with like doing
something new we did a bunch of new
things and some worked out great and
some were bad
and we learned a lot from it and then
the next one we learned a lot
that also ev6 also had some really cool
things in it i think the proportion of
good stuff went
up but it had a couple of fatal flaws in
it that were
painful and then uh
yeah you learn to channel the pain into
like pride
not pride really you know just uh
realization about how the world works
okay or how that kind of ideas that
works
life is suffering that's the reality
what uh
no it's not well i know the buddha said
that and a couple other people
are stuck on it no it's you know there's
this kind of weird combination of good
and bad
you know light and darkness that you
have to tolerate and
you know deal with yeah there's
definitely lots of suffering in the
world
depends on the perspective it seems like
there's way more darkness but uh
that makes the light part really nice
what uh
computing hardware
or just any kind of even software design
are you
uh do you find beautiful from your own
work from
other people's work that you're just uh
we were just talking about the
the battleground of flaws and mistakes
and errors but things that were just
beautifully done is there something that
pops to mind
well when things are beautifully done
usually there's a well thought out set
of abstraction layers
so the whole thing works in unison
nicely yes
and and when i say abstraction layer
that means two different components when
they work together
they work independently they don't have
to know what the other one is doing
so that decoupling yeah so the famous
one was the the network stack like
there's a seven layer network
you know data transport and protocol and
all the layers
and the innovation was is when they
really wrote got that right
because networks before that didn't
define those very well the layers could
innovate independently and occasionally
the layer boundary would
you know the interface would be upgraded
and that that let
you know the the design space breathe
and
you could do something new in layer
seven without having to worry about how
layer four
worked right and so good design does
that and you see it in processor designs
when we did the zen design at amd
we made several components very modular
and you know my insistence at the top
was i wanted all the interfaces to find
before we wrote the rtl for the pieces
one of the verification leads said if we
do this right i can test the pieces
so well independently when we put it
together we won't find all these
interaction bugs because the floating
point knows how the cache works
and i was a little skeptical but he was
mostly right
that the modularity design greatly
improved the quality
is that universally true in general
would you say about good designs the
modularity is
like usually talked about this before
humans are only so smart like
and we're not getting any smarter right
but the complexity of things is going up
yeah so you know a beautiful design
can't be bigger than the person doing it
it's just you know their piece of it
like the odds of you doing a really
beautiful
design of something that's way too hard
for you is slow
right if it's way too simple for you
it's not that interesting it's like well
anybody could do that
but when you get the right match of your
your expertise and you know mental power
to the right design size
that's cool but that's not big enough to
make a meaningful impact in the world
so now you have to have some framework
to design the pieces
so that the whole thing is big and
harmonious
but you know when you put it together
it's
you know sufficiently sufficiently
interesting to to be used
and you know so that's like a beautiful
design is
matching the limits of that human
cognitive capacity
to uh to the module you can create and
creating a nice interface between those
modules
and thereby do you think there's a limit
to the kind of beautiful complex systems
we can build with this kind of modular
design it's like uh
you know if we build increasingly more
complicated you can think of like the
internet
okay let's scale it up you can think of
like social network like twitter
as one computing system
and but those are little modules yeah
right
but it's built on it's built on so many
components nobody at twitter even
understands right so
so so if an alien showed up and looked
at twitter he wouldn't just see twitter
as a beautiful simple thing that
everybody uses
which is really big you would see the
network
it runs on the fiber optics the data is
transported the computers the whole
thing is so bloody complicated
nobody twitter understands it and so i
think that's what the alienware sees
so yeah if an alien showed up and looked
at twitter or looked at the various
different
networked systems that you can see on
earth so imagine they were really smart
they could comprehend the whole thing
and then they sort of you know evaluated
the human and thought this is really
interesting no human on this planet
comprehends the system they built
no individual or well would they even
see individual humans that's the
interest
like we humans are very human-centric
entity-centric
and so we think of us as the organ as
the central organism and the networks as
just the connection of organisms
but from a perspective of an alien from
an outside perspective
it seems like yeah yeah i get it where
the ants and they'd see the ant colony
the ant colony yeah or the result the
production of the ant colony which is
like
cities and it's it's uh
yeah in that sense humans are pretty
impressive the modularity that we're
able to
and the and how robust we are to noise
and
mutation all that kind of stuff well
that's because it's stress tested all
the time
yeah you know you build all these cities
with buildings and you get earthquakes
occasionally and
you know some you know wars earthquakes
viruses every once in a while
you know changes in business plans for
you know like
shipping or something like like as long
as it's all stress tested then
it keeps adapting to the the situation
so
the that's that's a curious phenomena
well let's go let's talk about moore's
law a little bit
uh at the broad view
of moore's law was just exponential
improvement of uh
computing capability uh like openai for
example recently
published this kind of papers looking at
the exponential improvement in the
training efficiency of neural networks
for like image net and all that kind of
stuff we just got better on
this is purely software aside just
figuring out
better tricks and algorithms for
training neural networks
and that seems to be improving uh
significantly faster than the moore's
law prediction
you know so that's in the software space
like
what do you think if moore's law
continues or
if the general version of moore's law
continues
do you think that comes mostly from the
hardware from the software some mix of
the two
some interesting totally uh so not the
reduction of the size of the transistor
kind of thing but more in the uh
in the totally interesting kinds of
innovations in the hardware space all
that kind of stuff
well there's like a half a dozen things
going on in that graph
so one is there's initial innovations
that had a lot of had room to be
exploited
so you know the efficiency of the
networks has improved dramatically
and then the decomposability of those
and the use go you know they started
running on one computer then multiple
computers and multiple gpus and then
arrays of gpus and
they're up to thousands and at some
point
so so it's sort of like they were
consumed they were going from like a
single computer application to a
thousand
computer application so that's not
really a moore's law thing that's an
independent vector how many computers
can i put on this problem
because the computers themselves are
getting better on like a moore's law
rate
but their ability to go from one to ten
to a hundred to a thousand
yeah you know was something and then
multiplied by
you know the amount of computes it took
to resolve like alex net to resnet the
transformers it's
it's been quite you know steady
improvements
but those are like s cars aren't they
yeah that's the exactly kind of s-curves
that are underlying moore's law from the
very beginning
so so what what's the biggest what's the
most
uh productive uh rich
source of s-curves in in the future do
you think is it
hardware is it software or is it so
hardware is going to move along
relatively slowly like you know double
performance every two years
there are there's still i like how you
call that slow yeah that's the slow
version
the snail's pace of moore's law maybe we
should we should
we should uh trademark that one
whereas the scaling by number of
computers you know can go much faster
you know i'm sure at some point google
had a you know their initial search
engine was running on a laptop you know
like
yeah and at some point they really
worked on scaling that and then they
factored
the indexer from you know this piece and
this piece and this piece and they
spread the data on more things and you
know they did
a dozen innovations but as they scaled
up the number of computers on that
it kept breaking finding new bottlenecks
in their software and their schedulers
and
and made them rethink like it seems
insane to do a scheduler across a
thousand computers to schedule parts of
it and then send the results to one
computer
but if you want to schedule a million
searches that makes perfect sense
so so there's the the scaling by just
quantity is probably the richest
thing but then as you scale quantity
like a network that was great on 100
computers may be
completely the wrong one you may pick a
network that's 10 times slower
on 10 000 computers like per computer
but if you go from a hundred to ten
thousand that's a hundred times
so that's one of the things that
happened when we did internet scaling is
the efficiency went down
not up the future of computing is
inefficiency not efficiency
but scales in efficient scale it's it's
scaling faster than inefficiency
bites you and as long as there's you
know dollar value there like scaling
costs lots of money
yeah but google showed facebook showed
everybody showed that the scale was
where the money was
at it was and so it was worth it
financially do you think
is it possible that like basically the
entirety
of earth will be like a computing
surface like this table will be doing
computing
this hedgehog will be doing computing
like everything really inefficient dumb
computing would be
fiction books they call it computronium
computing we turn everything into
computing
well most of the elements aren't very
good for anything like you're not going
to make a computer out of iron like
you know silicon and carbon have like
nice structures
you know we'll we'll see what what you
can do with the rest of it
people talk about well maybe we can turn
the sun into computer but it's
it's hydrogen and a little bit of helium
so what i mean is more like actually
just
adding computers to everything oh okay
so you're just
converting all the mass of the universe
into a computer no no
so not using to be ironic from the
simulation point of view is like
the simulator build mass to simulate
like
yeah i mean yeah so i mean ultimately
this is all heading towards the
simulation yeah well
i i think i might have told you the
story a tesla they were deciding
so they want to measure the current
coming out of the battery and they
decide between putting the resistor in
there
and putting a computer with a sensor in
there
and the computer was faster than the
computer i worked on in 1982.
and we chose the computer because it was
cheaper than the resistor
so so sure this hedgehog you know it
costs 13
and we can put a you know an ai that's
the smartest you in there for five bucks
it'll have one
you know so computers will be you know
he'd be everywhere
i was hoping it wouldn't be smarter than
me because well everything's going to be
smarter than you
but you were saying it's inefficient i
thought it was better to have a lot of
doubt
well well moore's law will slowly
compact that stuff so even the dump
things will be smarter than us
the dump things are going to be smart or
they're going to be smart enough to talk
to something that's really smart
you know it's like well just remember
like
a big computer chip yeah you know it's
like an inch by an inch
and you know 40 microns thick
it doesn't take very much very many
atoms to make a high power computer
yeah and 10 000 of them can fit in the
shoe box
but you know you have the the cooling
and power problems but you know
people are working on that but they
still can't write
uh compelling poetry or music or uh
understand what love is or have a fear
of mortality so
so we're still winning neither can most
of humanity so
well they can write books about it so uh
[Laughter]
but but speaking about this uh you know
uh
this walk along the path of innovation
towards uh
the dumb things being smarter than
humans you are now
the cto of uh
tens torrent as of two months ago
they uh build hardware for deep learning
how do you build scalable and efficient
deep learning this is such a fascinating
space yeah yeah so it's interesting so
um
up until recently i thought there was
two kinds of computers there are serial
computers
that run like c programs and then
there's parallel computers
so the way i think about it is you know
parallel computers you
have given parallelism like gpus are
great because you have a million pixels
and modern gpus run a program on every
pixel they call the shader program
right so or like finite element analysis
you
you build something you know you make
this into little tiny chunks you give
each chunk to a computer
so you're giving all these chunks a
parallel something like that
but most c programs you write this
linear narrative
and you have to make it go fast to make
it go fast you predict all the branches
all the data fetches and you run that
more in parallel but that's found
parallelism
ai is i'm still trying to decide how
fundamental this is
it's a given parallelism problem but the
way people
describe the neural networks and then
how they write them in pi torch it makes
graphs yeah
that might be fundamentally different
than the gpu kind of parallelism yeah it
might be
because the when you run the gpu program
on all the pixels
you're running like you know depends you
know this group of pixels say it's
background blue and that runs a really
simple program this pixel is
you know some patch of your face so you
have some really interesting shader
program to give you impression of
translucency
but the pixels themselves don't talk to
each other there's no graph
right so you you do the image and then
you do the next image and you do the
next image
and you run 8 million pixels 8 million
programs every time and modern gpus have
like 6 000
thread engines in them so you know to
get 8 million pixels each one runs a
program on you know 10 or 20
pixels and that's how that's how they
work but there's no graph
but you think graph might be a totally
new way to think about hardware so raja
gadori and i've been having this good
conversation
about giving versus found parallelism
and then
the kind of walk cause we got more
transistors like you know computers way
back when did
stuff on scalar data then we did it on
vector data famous vector machines
now we're making computers that operate
on matrices
right and then the the category we we
said that was next was spatial
like imagine you have so much data that
you know you want to do the compute on
this data
and then when it's done it says send the
result to this pile of data run some
software on that
and it's better to to think about it
spatially than
to move all the data to a central
processor and do all the work
so especially i mean moving in the space
of data as opposed to moving the data
yeah you have a you have a petabyte data
space spread across some huge array of
computers
and when you do a computation somewhere
you send the result of that computation
or maybe
a pointer to the next program some other
piece of data and do it
but i think a better word might be graph
and all the ai neural networks are
graphs
do some computations send the result
here do another computation do a data
transformation do a merging do a pooling
do another computation is it possible to
compress and say
how we make this thing efficient this
whole process efficient
that's different so first uh
the fundamental elements in the graphs
are things like matrix multiplies
convolutions data manipulations and data
movements
so gpus emulate those things with their
little singles
you know basically running a single
threaded program
and then there's a you know nvidia calls
it a work where they group a bunch of
programs that are similar together
so for efficiency and instruction use
and then at a higher level you kind of
you take this graph and you say this
part of the graph is a matrix multiplier
which runs on these
32 threads but the model at the bottom
was
built for running programs on pixels not
executing graphs
so it's emulation yes so is it possible
to build something that natively runs
graphs
yes so that's what ten storm did
so where are we on that how like in the
history of that effort
are we in the early days yeah i think so
tense torrance
started by a friend of mine labisha
bajak and i
i was his first investor so i've been
you know kind of
following him and talking to him about
it for years and
in the fall when i was considering
things to do
i decided you know the we we held a
conference last year with a
friend organized it and and we we wanted
to bring in thinkers
and two of the people were andre
carpassi and chris lattner
and andre gave this talk on youtube
called software 2.0
which i think is great which is we went
from
programmed computers where you write
programs to data program computers
you know like the futures you know of
software as data programs the the
networks
and i think that's true and then
chris has been work he worked on llvm
the low-level virtual machine which
became the intermediate representation
for all compilers
and now he's working on another project
called mlir which is mid-level
intermediate representation which is
essentially under the graph about how do
you represent that kind of computation
and then coordinate large numbers of
potentially heterogeneous computers
and and i would say technically tense
torrents
you know two pillars are those those
those two ideas software 2.0 and
mid-level representation
but it's in service of executing graph
programs
the hardware is designed to do that so
it's including the hardware
piece yeah and then the other cool thing
is
for a relatively small amount of money
they did a test chip and two production
chips
so it's like a super effective teams and
and unlike some ai startups where if you
don't build the hardware to run the
software that they really want to do
then you have to fix it by writing lots
more software
so the hardware naturally does matrix
multiply convolution the data
manipulations
and the data movement between processing
elements that
that you can see in the graph which i
think is all pretty clever
and that's that's what i'm i'm working
on now
so uh the i think it's called the grace
call
processor uh introduced last year it's
uh
you know there's a bunch of measures of
performance we're talking about horses
it seems to outperform 368 trillion
operations per second seems to
outperform nvidia's tesla t4 system so
these are just numbers
what do they actually mean in real world
perform like what are the
metrics for you that you're chasing in
in your horse race like what do you care
about
well first so the the native language of
you know people who write ai network
programs is pie torch now by torch
tensorflow there's a couple others
the pi torch is one over tensor flows
it's just i'm not an expert on that
i i know many people have switched from
tensorflow to pi torch
yeah and there's technical reasons for
it and i use both
both are still awesome both are still
awesome but the deepest
love is for pytorch currently yeah
there's more love for that and that that
may change
so the first thing is when they write
their programs
can the hardware execute it pretty much
as it was written
right so pi torch turns into a graph we
have a graph compiler that makes that
graph
then it fractions the graph down so if
you have a big matrix multiply we turn
it into right-sized chunks that run on
the processing elements
it hooks all the graph up it lays out
all the data there's a couple mid-level
representations of it that are also
simulatable so that
if you're writing the code you can see
how it's going to go through the machine
which is pretty cool and then at the
bottom it schedules kernels like
math data manipulation data movement
kernels which do this stuff
so we don't have to run write a little
program to do matrix multiply because we
have a big matrix multiplier
like there's no cmd program for that
but there is scheduling for that right
so the the
one of the goals is if you write a piece
of pytorch code that looks pretty
reasonable you should be able to compile
it run it on the hardware
without having to tweak it and and do
all kinds of crazy things to get
performance
there's not a lot of intermediate steps
right it's running directly as right
like on a gpu if you write a large
matrix multiply naively you'll get five
to ten percent of the peak performance
of the gpu
right and then there's a bunch there's a
bunch of people publish papers on this
and i read them about
what steps do you have to do and it goes
from pretty reasonable
well transpose one of the matrices so
you wrote or not column ordered
you know block it so that you can put a
block of the matrix on different
sms you know groups of threads
but some of it gets into little details
like you have to schedule it just so so
you don't have registered conflicts
so the the the they call them cuda
ninjas
i love it to get to the optimal point
you either write a pre
use a pre-written library which is a
good strategy for some things
or you have to be an expert in micro
architecture to program it
right so the optimization step is way
more complicated with the gpa so our
our goal is if you write pi torch that's
good pi torch you can do it
now there's as the networks are evolving
you know they've changed from
convolutional to matrix multiply
people are talking about conditional
graphs you're talking about very large
matrices they're talking about sparsity
you're talking about problems that scale
across many many chips
so the the native you know
data item is a as a packet like so you
send a packet to a processor it gets
processed
it does a bunch of work and then it may
send packets to other processors and
and they execute like a data flow graph
kind of methodology
got it we have a big network on chip and
then 16
the next second chip has 16 ethernet
ports they hook lots of them together
and it's the same graph compiler across
multiple chips so that's where the scale
comes in so it's built to scale
naturally
now my experience with scaling is as you
scale you run into lots of interesting
problems
so scaling is the mountain to climb yeah
so the hardware is built to do this and
then
we're in the process of is there a
software part to this
with ethernet and all that well the
you know the protocol at the bottom you
know we send you know it's an ethernet
phi but the protocol basically says
send a packet from here to there it's
all point to point
the header bit says which processor to
send it to and we basically
take a packet off our on-chip network
put an ethernet header on it
send it to the other end to strip the
header off and send it to the local
thing it's pretty straightforward
human human interaction is pretty
straightforward too but when you get a
million of us we could
do some crazy stuff together it could be
fun
so is that the goal is scale so like for
example i've
been recently doing a bunch of robots at
home for my own personal pleasure
uh am i going to ever use 10 story or is
this more for
there's all kinds of problems like
they're small inference problems or
small training problems there's big
training problems
what's the big goal is it the big
difference uh training problems or the
small training problems
well one of the goals is to scale from
100 milliwatts to a
to a megawatt you know so like really
have some range on the problems and
the same kind of ai programs work at all
different levels
so that's cool the natural since the
natural data item is a packet that
we can move around it's built to scale
but so many people have you know small
problems
right right but but uh you know like
inside that phone is a small problem
to solve so do you see that storm
potentially being inside a phone well
the power efficiency of local memory
local computation
and the way we built it is pretty good
and then
there's a lot of efficiency on being
able to do conditional graphs and
sparsity
i think it for complicated networks i
want to go in a small factor it's been
quite good
um but we have to prove that that's a
that's a fun problem and that's the
early days of the company right it's a
couple years you said
but you think you invested you think
they're legit yeah as you join yeah well
that's well it's also it's a really
interesting place to be
like the ai world is exploding you know
and
i looked at some other opportunities
like build a faster processor which
people want
yes but that's more on incremental path
than
what's going to happen in ai in the next
10 years
so this is kind of you know an exciting
place to be part of
the revolutions will be happening in the
very space and then
lots of people are working on it but
there's lots of technical reasons why
some of them you know aren't going to
work out that well
and and you know that's that's
interesting and there's also the same
problem about getting the basics right
like we've talked to customers about
exciting features
and at some point we realized that each
unit was realizing
they want to hear first about memory
bandwidth local bandwidth compute
intensity
programmability they want to know the
basics power management
how the network ports work what are the
basics do all the basics work
because it's easy to say we got this
great idea that you know the crack gbt3
but the the people we talked to want to
say
if i buy that so we have a pc express
card
with our chip on it if you buy the card
you plug it in your machine you download
the driver how long does it take me to
get my network to run
right right you know that's a real
question it's a very basic question
so yeah is there an answer to that yet
or is it trying to our goal is like an
hour
okay when can i buy a tesla uh
pretty soon for my for the small case
training yeah pretty soon
months good i love the idea of you
inside the room with the
carpathi andre kapathi and chris ladner
uh very um
very interesting very brilliant people
very out of the box
thinkers but also like first principles
thinkers well they both
get stuff done they only get stuff done
to get their own projects done they
they talk about it clearly they educate
large numbers of people and they've
created platforms for other people to go
do their stuff on
yeah the the clear thinking that's able
to be communicated is kind of
impressive it's kind of remarkable to
yeah i'm a fan well let me ask because
uh
i talked to chris actually a lot these
days he's been uh
one of the cool just to give him a shout
out and he's been
so supportive as a human being so
everybody's quite different like great
engineers are different but he's been
like
sensitive to the human element in a way
that's been fascinating
like he was one of the early people on
this stupid podcast that i do to say
like
don't quit this thing and also
talk to whoever the hell you want to
talk to
that kind of from a legit engineer to
get like
props and be like you can do this that
was
i mean that's what a good leader does
right they just kind of
let a little kid do his thing like go go
do it let's see
let's see see what turns out that that's
a that's a pretty powerful thing but
what do you um what's your sense about
he used to be
he no i think stepped away from google
right
he said sci-fi i think uh
what what's really impressive to you
about the things that chris has worked
on because it's that we mentioned the
optimization
the compiled design stuff the llvm uh
then there's he's also a google work
that the tpu stuff
he's obviously worked on swift so the
programming language side
talking about people that work in the
entirety of the stack yeah
uh what uh from your time interacting
with chris
and knowing the guy what's really
impressive to you it just inspires you
well well like llvm became
you know the platform the de facto
platform for
you know compilers like it's it's
amazing
and you know it was good code quality
good design choices he hit the right
level of abstraction
there's a little bit of the right time
in the right place
and then he built a new programming
language called swift
which you know after you know let's say
some adoption resistance became very
successful
i don't know that much about his work at
google although i know that
you know that was the typical they
started
tensorflow stuff and they you know it
was new is you know
they wrote a lot of code and then at
some point it needed to be refactored
to be you know because it its
development slowed down why
pytorch started a little later and then
passed it so he did a lot of work on
that
and then his idea about mlir which is
what people started to realize is the
complexity of the software stack above
the low level ir was getting so high
that forcing the features of that into a
level
was was putting too much of a burden on
it so he's splitting that into multiple
pieces
and that was one of the inspirations for
our software stack where we have
several intermediate representations
that are all executable
and you can look at them and do
transformations on them before you lower
the level
so that was i think we started before
moir
really got you know far enough along to
use
uh but we're interested in that he's
really excited about that malaya
he's that's that's his like little baby
so he you know
and there seems to be some profound
ideas on that that are really useful so
so each one of those things has been
as the world of software gets more and
more complicated how do we
create the right abstraction levels to
simplify it in a way that
people can now work independently on
different levels of it
so i would say all all three of those
projects allovm
swift and mlir did that successfully so
i'm interested what's
what he's going to do next in the same
kind of way yes
so on either the tpu or maybe the
nvidia gpu side how does 10 story you
think
or the ideas underlying it doesn't have
to be testosterone
just this kind of graph focused
uh graph centric hardware
deep learning-centric hardware beat
nvidia's
do you think it's possible for it to
basically overtake nvidia
sure what's what's that process look
like what's that
a journey look like you think well gpus
were built around shader programs on
millions of pixels
not to run graphs yes so there's a
hypothesis that says
the way the graphs you know are built
is going to be really interesting to be
inefficient on computing this
and then the the primitives is not a cmd
program
it's matrix multiply convolution and
then the data manipulations are fairly
extensive about
like how do you do a fast transpose with
a program i don't know if you've ever
written the transpose program
they're ugly and slow but in hardware
you can do really well
like i'll give you an example so when
gpu accelerators first started doing
triangles
like so you have a triangle which maps
on the set of pixels
so you build it's very easy
straightforward to build a hardware
engine that will find all those pixels
and it's kind of weird because you walk
along the triangle to get to the edge
and then you have to go back down to the
next row and walk along and then you
have to decide on the edge
if the line of the triangle is like half
on the pixel
what's the pixel color because it's half
of this pixel and half the next one
that's called rasterization
because you're saying that could be done
in uh in hardware now
that's an example of that operation as a
software program is really bad
i've written a program that did
rasterization the hardware that does it
has actually less code than
the software program that does it and
it's way faster
right so there are certain times when
the abstraction you have rasterize a
triangle
you know execute a graph you know
components of a graph
the right thing to do in the hardware
software boundary is for the hardware to
naturally do it
and so the gpu is really optimized for
the rasterization of triangles
well no that's just well like in a
modern you know
that's a small piece of modern gpus what
they did is
that they still rasterize triangles when
you're running the game but for the most
part
most of the computation in the area the
gpu is running shader programs
but they're single threaded programs on
pixels not graphs
let's be honest to say i don't actually
know the the math behind shader
shading and lighting and all that kind
of stuff i don't know what
they look like little simple floating
point programs or complicated ones you
can have 8 000 instructions in a shader
program
but i i don't have a good intuition why
it could be parallelized so easily
no it's because you have 8 million
pixels in every single so when you have
a light
right yeah that comes down the angle you
know the amount of light
like like say this is a line of pixels
across this table
right the amount of light on each pixel
is subtly different
and each pixel is responsible for
figuring out what figure it out so that
pixel says on this pixel i know the
angle of the light i know the occlusion
i know the color i am
like every single pixel here is a
different color every single pixel gets
a different amount of light
every single pixel has a subtly
different translucency
so to make it look realistic the
solution was you run a separate program
on every pixel
see but i thought there's a reflection
from all over the place is every picture
yeah but there is
so so you build a reflection map which
also has some pixelated thing
and then when the pixel is looking at
the reflection map it has to calculate
what the normal of the surface is
and it does it per pixel by the way
there's both loads of hacks on that
you're like you may have a lower
resolution
light map reflection map there's all
these you know attacks they do
but at the end of the day it's per pixel
computation
and it so happened that you can map uh
graph
like computation onto the this pixel
essentially
you could do floating point programs on
convolutions and matrices
and nvidia invested for years in cuda
first for hpc and then they got lucky
with the ai
trend but do you think they're going to
essentially not be able to
hardcore pivot out of their we'll see
that's always interesting how often do
big companies hardcore pivot
occasionally
how much do you know about nvidia folks
so
some yeah well i'm i'm curious as well
who's ultimately as a
well they've innovated several times but
they've also worked really hard on
mobile they worked really hard on radios
you know you know they're fundamentally
a gpu company
well they tried to pivot it's an
interesting little uh
game and play in autonomous vehicles
right with
or semi-autonomous like playing with
tesla and so on and seeing
that's a dipping a toe into that kind of
pivot
they came out with this platform which
is interesting technically
yeah but it was like a three thousand
watt you know
you know thousand watt three three
thousand dollar you know gpu platform
i don't know if it's interesting
technically it's interesting
philosophically i
i technically i don't know if it's the
execution that craftsmanship was there
i'm not sure but that i didn't get a
sense they were
repurposing gpus for an automotive
solution right it's not a real pivot
they didn't they didn't build a
ground-up
solution right like the like the chips
inside tesla are pretty cheap like
mobile eye has been doing this
they're they're doing the classic work
from the simplest thing yeah you know
they were building 40 mil
square millimeter chips and nvidia their
solution had two
800 millimeter chips and two 200
millimeter chips and
you know like boatloads are really
expensive drams and
and you know it's a really different
approach
the mobilelite fit the let's say
automotive cost and form factor
and then they added features as it was
economically viable and
nvidia said take the biggest thing and
we're gonna go make it work
you know and and that's also influenced
like waymo there's a whole bunch of
autonomous startups where they have a
5000 watt server in their trunk
right and but that's that's because they
think well 5000 watts and you know 10
000
is okay because it's replacing the
driver elon's approach was that port has
to be cheap enough
to put it in every single tesla whether
they turn on it autonomous driving or
not
which and mobileye was like we need to
fit in the bomb and you know cost
structure that
car companies do so they may sell you a
gps for 1500 bucks
but the bond for that's like 25
well and uh for mobile eye it seems like
neural networks
were not first-class citizens like the
computation they didn't start out as
a yeah it was a cv problem yeah and did
classic cv and found stop lights and
lines and they were really good at it
yeah and they never i mean i don't know
what's happening now but they never
fully pivoted i mean it's like it's the
nvidia thing and then
as opposed to so if you look at the new
tesla work
it's like neural networks from the
ground up yeah right
yeah and even tesla started with a lot
of cv stuff in it and andre's basically
been
eliminating it move it move
everything into the network so uh
without
this isn't like confidential stuff but
you sitting on a porch
looking over the world looking at the
work that andre is doing
that elon's doing with tesla autopilot
uh do you like the trajectory of where
things are going on the floor
they're making serious progress i like
the videos of people
driving the beta stuff like it's taking
some pretty complicated intersections
and all that but it's
it's still an intervention for drive i
mean i i have autopilot the current
autopilot my
my tesla i use it every day do you have
full self-driving beta or no
no so you you like where this is going
we're making progress it's taking longer
than anybody thought
you know my wonder was
is you know hardware three is it enough
computing
off by two off by five off by ten off by
a hundred
yeah and and i i thought it probably
wasn't enough
but they're doing pretty well with it
now yeah and one thing is
the data set gets bigger the training
gets better and then there's this
interesting thing is
you sort of train and build an arbitrary
size network that solves the problem
and then you refactor the network down
to the thing that you can afford
to ship right so the the goal isn't to
build the network that fits in the phone
it's to build something that actually
works
and then then how do you make that most
effective on the hardware you have
and they seem to be doing that much
better than a couple years ago
well the one really important thing is
also what they're doing well is
how to iterate that quickly which means
like it's not just about one time
deployment one building is constantly
entering the network
and trying to automate as many steps as
possible right
and that's actually the principles of
the software 2.0 like you mentioned with
andre
is uh it's not just
i mean i don't know what the actual his
description of software 2.0 is
if it's just high-level philosophical or
their specifics but the
interesting thing about what that
actually looks in the real world
is it's that uh what i think andre calls
the data engine it's like
it's the iterative improvement of the
thing you have a neural network
that uh does stuff fails on a bunch of
things and learns from it over and over
and over so you're constantly
discovering edge cases
so it's very much about uh like data
engineering like
figuring out it's it's kind of what you
were talking about with testosterone is
you have the data landscape
they have to walk along that data
landscape in a way that uh
that's constantly improving the the the
neural network and that that feels like
that's the central piece of it yeah
itself and there's two pieces of it like
you you find edge cases that don't work
and then you define something that goes
get your data for that
but then the other constraint is whether
you have to label it or not like the
the amazing thing about like the gpt3
stuff is it's unsupervised
so there's essentially infinite amount
of data now there's obviously infinite
amount of data
available from cars of people
successfully driving
but you know the the current pipelines
are mostly running on labeled data which
is human limited
so when that becomes unsupervised
right it it'll create unlimited amount
of data which then they'll scale
now the networks that may use that data
might be way too big for cars
but then there'll be the transformation
from now we have unlimited data i know
exactly what i want
now can i turn that into something that
fits in the car
and that pro that process is going to
happen all over the place
every time you get to the place where
you have unlimited data and that's what
software 2.0 is about
unlimited data training networks to do
stuff
without humans writing code to do it and
ultimately also trying to discover like
you're saying the self-supervised
formulation of the problem so the
unsupervised formulation of the problem
like uh you know in driving there's this
really interesting
thing which is you look at a scene
that's before you and you have data
about what a successful human driver did
in that scene you know one second later
it's a little piece of data that you can
use just like with gpt-3 as training
currently even even though tesla says
they're using that it's an open question
to me
how much how far can you can you sell
all of the driving with just
that self-supervised piece of data
and like i i think that's what comedy is
doing
that's what common ai is doing but the
question is how
how much data so what comedy ai doesn't
have
is as good of a data engine for example
as tesla does that's where the
like the organization of the data i mean
as far as i know i haven't talked to
george
but they do have the data the question
is how much data is needed
because we say infinite very loosely
here uh it's it's
and then the other question which you
said i don't know if you think it's
still an open question is
are we in the right order of magnitude
for the compute necessary
that is is this is it like what elon
said this
chip that's in there now is enough to do
full self-driving
or do we need another order of magnitude
i think nobody actually knows the answer
to that question
i like the confidence that elon has but
yeah we'll see
and there's another funny thing is you
don't learn to drive with infinite
amounts of data
you learn to drive with an intellectual
framework that understands physics and
color and horizontal surfaces and laws
and roads and
you know all your your uh experience
from manipulating your environment
like look there's so many factors go
into that so then when you learn to
drive
like driving is a subset of this
conceptual framework that you have
right and so with self-driving cars
right now we're teaching them to drive
with driving data
you never teach a human to do that you
teach a human all kinds of interesting
things like
language like don't do that you know
watch out you know there's all kinds of
stuff going on well this is where you i
think previous time with we talked about
where you poetically uh disagreed with
my naive
uh notion about humans i just think that
humans will will make this whole driving
thing really difficult
yeah all right like i said humans don't
move that slow
it's a ballistics problem it's a
ballistic human zero ballistics problem
which is like poetry to me
it's very it's very possible that in
driving they're indeed purely a
ballistics problem i
and i think that's probably the right
way to think about it but
i still they still continue to surprise
me those
and damn pedestrians the cyclists other
humans and other cars
and yeah but it's going to be one of
these compensating things so
like when you're driving you have an
intuition about what humans are going to
do
but you don't have 360 cameras and
radars and you have an attention problem
so yeah
so so the self-driving car comes in with
no attention problems 360 cameras right
you know
a bunch of other features yeah so
they'll wipe out a whole class of
accidents
right and you know you know emergency
braking with radar and
especially as it gets you know ai
enhanced will eliminate collisions
right but then you have the other
problems of these unexpected things
where
you know you think your human intuition
is helping but then the cars also have
you know a set of hardware features that
you're not even close to
and the key thing of course is uh if you
wipe out
a huge number of kind of accidents then
it might be just way
safer than the human driver even though
even if humans are still a problem
that's hard to figure out yeah that's
probably what happens autonomous cars
will have
a small number of accidents humans would
have avoided but they'll wipe
they'll get rid of the bulk of them what
do you think about
uh like tesla's dojo efforts
or it can be bigger than tesla in
general it's kind of like the tense
torrent
uh trying to innovate like this is the
dichotomy like
should a company try to from scratch
build its own
neural network training hardware well
first i think it's great
so we need lots of experiments right and
there's lots of
startups working on this and they're
pursuing different things
you know i was there when we started
dojo and it was sort of like
what's the unconstrained computer
solution
to go do very large training problems
and then there's fun stuff like you know
we said well we have this 10 000 watt
board to cool
well you go talk to guys at spacex and
they think 10 000 watts is a really
small number not a big number
yeah and and there's brilliant people
working on it i'm
curious to see how it'll come out i i
couldn't tell you you know
i know it pivoted a few times since i
left so so the
cooling does seem to be a big problem i
do like what
elon said about it which is like we
don't want to do the thing
unless it's way better than the
alternative whatever the alternative
is so it has to be way better than like
racks of gpus yeah and the other thing
is just like
you know you know the tesla autonomous
driving hardware
it was only serving one software stack
and the hardware team and the software
team were tightly coupled
you know if you're building a general
purpose ai solution then you know
there's so many different customers with
so many different needs
now something andre said is i think this
is amazing
10 years ago like vision recommendation
language were completely different
disciplines
we said the people literally couldn't
talk to each other and three years ago
it was all neural networks but the very
different neural networks
and recently it's converging on one set
of networks they vary a lot in size
obviously they vary in data
varying outputs but the technology has
converged a good bit
yeah these transformers behind gbt3 it
seems like they could be applied to
video they could be applied to a lot of
yeah and it's like and they're all
really
it was like to literally replace letters
with pixels
yeah it does vision it's amazing so
and then size actually improves the
thing so the bigger it gets the more
compute you throw at it the better it
gets
the more data you have the better it
gets so
so so then you start to wonder well is
that a fundamental thing or is
is this just another step to some
fundamental understanding about this
kind of computation
which is really interesting us humans
don't want to believe that that kind of
thing will achieve conceptual
understandings you were saying like
you'll figure out physics but maybe it
will
maybe probably will well it's worse than
that
it'll understand physics in ways that we
can't understand i like to hear stephen
will from
talk where he said you know there's
three generations of physics there was
physics by reasoning well big things
should false faster than small things
right
that's reasoning and then there's
physics by equations
like you know but the number of programs
in the world that are solved with the
single equations relatively low almost
all programs have you know
more than one line of code maybe 100
million lines of code
so you said that now we're going to
physics by equation which is his project
which is cool
i might point out that there was there
was two
two generations of physics before
reasoning
habit like all animals you know know
things fall and you know birds fly and
you know predators know how to you know
solve a differential equation to cut off
a
accelerating you know curving animal
path yep and then there was uh you know
the gods did it
right so yeah right so
you know there's five generations now
software 2.0 says programming things is
not the last step
data so there's going to be a physics
past stephen's
wolfram's com that's not explainable
and and actually there's no reason that
i can see while that even that's the
limit
like there's something beyond that i
mean they're usually like usually when
you have this hierarchy it's not like
well if you have this step in this step
in this step and they're all
qualitatively different
and conceptually different it's not
obvious why you know six is the right
hand number of hierarchy steps in not
seven or eight or
well then it's probably impossible for
us to to comprehend
something that's beyond the thing that's
not explainable
yeah because i think but the thing that
you know understands the thing that's
unexplainable to us
we'll conceive the next one and like i'm
not sure why there's a limit to it
uh your brain hurts that's the sad story
if if we look at our own brain which is
an interesting uh
illustrative example in your work with
testor
and trying to design deep learning
architectures
uh do you do you think about the brain
at all
maybe from a hardware designer
perspective
if you could uh change something about
the brain what would you change
or do funny question like how would you
so your brain is really weird like you
know your cereal cortex where we think
we do most of our thinking
is what like six or seven neurons thick
yeah like
that's weird like all the big networks
are way bigger than that
like way deeper so that seems odd
and then you know when you're thinking
if it's if if the input generates a
result you can lose it goes really fast
but if it can't that generates an output
that's interesting which turns into an
input and then your brain
to the point where you mold things over
for days and how many trips through your
brain
is that right like it's you know 300
milliseconds or something to get through
seven levels of neurons
i forget the number exactly but then it
does it over and over and over as it
searches
and the brain clearly is looks like some
kind of graph because you have a neuron
with you know connections and it talks
to other ones and
it's locally very computationally
intense but it's also
does sparse computations across a pretty
big area
there's a lot of messy biological type
of things and it's
it's meaning like first of all there's
mechanical chemical and electrical
signals that's all that's going on
then the there's a the asynchronicity
of signals and there's like there's just
a lot of variability that seems
continuous and messy and just a
mess of biology and it's unclear whether
that's a
good thing yeah or it's a bad thing
because if
if it's a good thing that we need to run
the entirety of the evolution
well we're going to have to start with
basic bacteria to create some imaging
we could you could build a brain with 10
layers would that be better or worse
or more more connections or less
connections or you know
we don't know to what level our brains
are optimized
but if i was changing things like yeah
like you know you can only hold like
seven numbers
in your head yeah like why not 100 or a
million
never thought of that like and why can't
like why can't we have like a floating
point processor that can compute
anything we want
like and see it all properly like that
would be kind of fun
and why can't we we see in four or eight
dimensions
like because you know 3d is kind of a
drag
like all the hard mass transforms are up
in multiple dimensions
so there's that you know you could
imagine a brain architecture that
you know you could enhance with a whole
bunch of features that would be
you know really useful for thinking
about things it's possible that the
limitations you're describing are
actually
essential for like the constraints are
essential for creating
like the depth of intelligence like that
the ability to reason you know it's hard
to say because
like your brain is clearly a parallel
processor
you know you know 10 billion neurons
talking to each other at a relatively
low clock rate
but it produces something that looks
like a serial thought process
it's a serial narrative in your head
that's true right but then
there are people famously who are visual
thinkers like
i think i'm a relatively visual thinker
i can imagine any object
and rotate it in my head and look at it
and there are people who say they don't
think that way at all
and recently i read an article about
people people who say they don't have a
they don't have a voice in their heads
they
can talk but when they you know it's
like well what are you thinking
they'll they'll describe something
that's visual
so that's curious
now if if you're saying
if we dedicated more hardware to holding
information like you know
10 numbers or a million numbers like
would that
just distract us from our ability to
form this kind of
singular identity like it dissipates
somehow right
but but maybe you know future humans
will have many identities that
have some higher level organization but
can actually do lots more things in
parallel
yeah there's no reason if we're thinking
modularly there's no reason we can't
have multiple consciousnesses in one
brain
yeah and maybe there's some way to make
it faster so that the
you know the the area the computation
could
could still have a unified feel to it
but while still having way more ability
to do parallel stuff at the same time
could definitely be improved it could be
improved okay
well it's it's pretty good right now
actually people don't give it enough
credit the thing is pretty nice the
the you know the the fact that the right
ends seem to be
on give a nice like spark
of uh beauty to the whole experience
i don't know i don't know if it can be
improved easily it could be more
beautiful
i don't know how yeah what do you mean
what do you mean how
all the ways you can't imagine no but
that's the whole point
i wouldn't be able to i'm at the fact
that i can imagine ways in
in in which it could be more beautiful
means
so do you know you know ian banks his
stories
so the the super smart ais there
live mostly live in the world of what
they call infinite fun
because they can create arbitrary
worlds so they interact and you know the
story has it they interact in the normal
world and they're very smart and they
can do all kinds of stuff
and you know a given mind can you know
talk to a million humans at the same
time because we're very slow and
for reasons you know artificial the
story they're interested in people and
doing stuff but
they mostly live in this this other land
of thinking
my inclination is to think that the
ability to create infinite fun will
um will not be so fun
that's sad there are so many things to
do imagine be able to make a star
move planets around yeah yeah but
because we can imagine that as wildlife
is fun
if we can if we actually were able to do
it it'd be a slippery slope
where fun wouldn't even have a meaning
because we just consistently
desensitize ourselves by the infinite
amounts of fun we're having
and the sadness uh the the dark stuff is
what makes it fun
i think i mean that could be the russian
it could be the
could be the fun makes it fun and the
sadnesses makes it bittersweet
yeah that's true fun could be uh the
thing that makes it fun
so what do you think about the expansion
not through the biology side but through
the bci the brain computer interfaces
yeah you got a chance to check out the
neural link stuff it's super interesting
like like humans like like our thoughts
to manifest as action
you know like like as a kid you know
like shooting a rifle was super fun
driving a mini bike doing things and
then computer games i think
for a lot of kids became the thing where
they you know they can do what they want
they can fly a
plane they can do this they can do this
right but you have to
have this physical interaction now
imagine
you know you could just imagine stuff
and it happens
right like really richly
and interestingly like we kind of do
that when we dream like dream
dreams are funny because like if you
have some control or awareness in your
dreams
like it's very realistic looking or not
realistic
it depends on the dream but you can also
manipulate that
and you know what what's possible there
is is
is odd and the fact that nobody
understands it's hilarious but
um do you think it's possible to expand
that capability through computing
sure is there some interesting so from a
hardware designer perspective
is there do you think you'll present
totally new challenges and the kind of
hardware that
required that like so this hardware
isn't
standalone computing well this just
knows
today computer games are rendered by
gpus
right right so but you've seen the gans
stuff
yep right where trained neural networks
render realistic images but there's no
pixels no triangles no shaders
no light maps no nothing so the future
of
graphics is probably ai right yes
now that ai is heavily trained by lots
of real
data right so if you have an interface
with a
aai renderer right
so if you say render a cat it won't say
well how tall is the cat and how big it
you know it'll render a cat and you
might say well a little bigger a little
smaller you know
make it a tabby shorter hair you know
like you could tweak it
like the the amount of data you'll have
to
send to interact with a very powerful ai
renderer
could be low but the question is for
brain computer interfaces
would need to render not onto a screen
but
render onto the brain and
like directly so that there's a
bandwidth you could do it both ways i
mean our eyes are really good sensors
it could render onto a screen and
we could feel like we're participating
in it you know they're gonna
they're gonna have you know like the
oculus kind of stuff it's gonna be so
good when a projection to your eyes you
think it's real
you know they're slowly solving those
problems
and i suspect when the renderer
of that information into your head is
also ai mediated
you know they'll be able to give you the
cues that you know you really want for
depth and all kinds of stuff like your
your brain is probably faking your your
visual
field right like your eyes are twitching
around but you don't notice that
occasionally they blank you don't notice
that you know there's all kinds of
things like you think you see over here
but you don't really see there yeah it's
all fabricated
yeah so yeah peripheral vision is
fascinating
so if you have an ai renderer that's
trained to understand
exactly how you see and the kind of
things that enhance the realism of the
experience
it could be super real actually
so i don't know what the limits that are
but
obviously if if we have a brain
interface that goes in
inside your you know visual cortex in a
better way than your eyes do
which is possible it's a lot neurons
yeah um maybe that will be even
cooler well the really cool thing is it
has to do with the
the infinite fun that you're referring
to which is our brains seem to be very
limited and like you said computational
so very plastic
very plastic yeah yeah so it's a it's a
com interesting combination
now the the interesting open question is
the limits of that neuroplasticity like
how how flexible is that thing
because we don't we haven't really
tested it we know about that experiments
where they they put like a pressure pad
on somebody's head
and had a visual transducer pressurize
it and somebody slowly learned to see
yep that's like it's especially at a
young age
if you throw a lot at it like what what
can it uh
uh can it completely so can you like
arbitrarily expand it with computing
power so
connected to the internet directly
somehow yeah the answer's probably yes
so the problem with biology and ethics
is like there's a mess there
like us humans are perhaps unwilling to
take
risks in uh into directions that are
full of uncertainty
so that's like 90 of the population is
unwilling to take risks the other 10
is rushing into the risks unaided by any
infrastructure whatsoever
and you know and that that's where all
the fun
happens in you know society there's been
huge transformations
yeah in the last you know a couple
thousand years yeah
it's funny i mean i got a chance to
interact with uh uh
this is matthew johnson from johns
hopkins he's doing this large-scale
study of psychedelics
it's it's becoming more and more i've
gotten a chance to interact with that
community of scientists working on
psychedelics
but because of that that opened the door
to me to
all these uh what are they called
psychonauts the
people who like you said the ten percent
who like
i don't care i don't know if there's a
science behind this i'm taking the
spaceship
to if i'm being the first on mars i'll
be uh
the you know you know psychedelic's
interesting in the sense that
in another dimension uh like you said
it's a way to explore the
with the limits of the human mind like
what is this thing capable of doing
because you kind of like when you dream
you detach it i don't know exactly in
your science of it but
you detach your like reality
from what your mind the images your mind
is able to conjure up and your mind goes
into weird places
and like entities appear freudian type
of
like trauma is probably connected in
there somehow but you start to have like
these
weird vivid worlds that like so do you
actively dream
do you why not i had like six six
hours of dreams and i it's like really
useful time i know
i do i haven't uh i don't for some
reason i just knock out
and uh i have sometimes like anxiety
inducing kind of like
very pragmatic like nightmare type of
dreams but not nothing fun nothing
nothing fun nothing fun i i try
i unfortunately have mostly have fun
in uh the waking world which is very
limited in the amount of fun you can
have
it's not that limited either yeah that's
what we'll have to talk
yeah i need instructions uh yeah there's
like a manual for that you might wanna
i looked it up i'll ask elon what uh
what did you dream
you know years ago and i i read about
you know
like you know a book about how to have
you know become aware of your dreams
i worked on it for a while like there's
this trick about you know imagine you
can see your hands and look out
and and i got somewhat good at it like
but my mostly when i'm thinking about
things or working on problems
i i i prep myself before i go to sleep
it's like
i i pull into my mind all the things i
want to work on or think about
and then that let's say greatly improves
the chances that i'll
i'll work on that while i'm sleeping
and then and then i also
you know basically asked to remember it
and i often remember very detailed
within the dream yeah or outside the
dream well
to bring it up in in my dreaming and
then remember it when i wake up
it's just it's more of a meditative
practice you say
you know to prepare yourself to do that
like if you go to you know the sleep
still gnashing your teeth about some
random thing that happened
that you're not that really interested
in you'll dream about it
that's really interesting maybe but but
you can direct your dreams
somewhat by prepping you know i'm going
to try that it's really interesting
like the most important the interesting
not like uh
what what did this guy send in an email
kind of like stupid worry stuff but like
fundamental problems you're actually
concerned about
prepping and interesting things you're
worried about or just you're reading or
you know some great conversation you had
or something
some adventure you want to have like
there's there's a lot of
space there and
and it seems to work that
you know my percentage of interesting
dreams and memories went up
is there uh is that the source of uh
if you were able to deconstruct like
where some of your best ideas came from
do is there a process that's at the core
of that
yeah like so some people you know walk
and think some people like in the shower
the best ideas hit them
if you talk about like newton apple
hitting them on the head
no i i found that a long time ago i'm i
process things somewhat slowly
so like in college i had friends that
could study at the last minute get an a
next day
i can't do that at all so i always front
loaded all the work
like i do all the problems early you
know
for finals like the last three days i
wouldn't look at a book
because i want you know because like a
new fact the day before
finals may screw up my understanding of
what i thought i knew so my
my goal was to always get it in and and
give it time to soak
and i used to you know i remember we
were doing like 3d calculus i would have
these amazing dreams of 3d surfaces with
normal
you know calculating the gradient and
this is like all come up so
it was really fun like very visual and
uh
and if i got cycles of that that was
useful
um and the other is don't over filter
your ideas
like i like that process of
brainstorming where lots of ideas can
happen i like people who have lots of
ideas
and things but that's what's up then
there's a yeah let them sit and let it
breathe a little bit
and then reduce it to practice like at
some point you really have to
does it really work like you know is
this real or not
right but you but you have to do both
there's creative tension there like how
do you
be both open and you know precise
if you had ideas that you just that sit
in your mind for like years
before the sure it's an interesting uh
way to is generate ideas and just let
them sit
let them sit there for a while
i think i have a few of those ideas you
know that was so funny
yeah i think that's you know creativity
uh this one or something for the slow
thinkers in the
in the room i suppose as i some people
like you said are just like
like the yeah it's really interesting
like there's so much diversity in how
people think
you know how fast or slow they are how
well they remember don't
like you know i'm not super good at
remembering facts but processes and
methods
like in our engineering i went to penn
state and almost all our engineering
tests were open book i could remember
the page and not the formula
but as soon as i saw the formula i could
remember the whole method if i
if i'd learned it yeah you know so it's
just a funny
or some people could you know i i
swatched friends like flipping through
the book trying to find the formula
even knowing that they'd done just as
much work and i would just open the book
i was on page 27
about half i could see the whole thing
visually
yeah and you know and you have to learn
that about yourself and figure out what
to do with the
function optimally i had a friend who he
was always concerned he didn't know how
he came up with ideas
he had lots of ideas but he said they
just sort of popped up
like you'd be working on something
having this idea like where does it come
from
but you can have more awareness of it
like like
like like how you how your brain works
is a little murky as you go down
from the voice in your head or the
obvious visualizations
like when you visualize something how
does that happen yes
you know if i say you know visualize
volcano it's easy to do right
and what does it actually look like when
you visualize it i can visualize to the
point where i don't see
very much out of my eyes and i see the
colors of the thing i'm visualizing
yeah but there's like a there's a shape
there's a texture there's a color but
there's also conceptual visualization
like
what are you actually visualizing when
you're visualizing volcano just like
with peripheral vision you think you see
the whole thing yeah yeah
that's a good way to say it you know you
have this kind of
almost peripheral vision of your
visualizations they're like these ghosts
but if you know if you if you work on it
you can get a pretty high level of
detail
and somehow you can walk along those
visualizations to come up with an idea
which is uh
but weird but when you're thinking about
solving problems
like you're you're putting information
and you're exercising the stuff you do
know
you're sort of teasing the area that's
you don't understand and don't know
but you can almost you know feel
you know that process happening you know
that's that's how i
like like like i know sometimes when i'm
working really hard on something like
like i get really hot when i'm sleeping
and you know it's like
we got the blank throw i wake up all the
blankets are on the floor
and you know every time it's while i
wake up and think wow that was great
you know are you able to uh to reverse
engineer what the hell happened there
oh sometimes it's vivid dreams and
sometimes it's this kind of like you say
like shadow thinking that you you sort
of have this feeling you're
you're going through this stuff but it's
it's not that obvious isn't that so
amazing that the mind just
does all these little experiments i
never you know i thought i always
thought
it's like a river that you can't you're
just there for the ride but you're right
if you prep
it no it's all understandable meditation
really helps
you you got to start figuring out you
need to learn language of your own mind
and there's multiple levels of it but
the abstractions again right it's
somewhat comprehensible and observable
and
feelable or whatever the right word is
no it's
you know you're not long for the ride
you are the ride
i have to ask you hardware engineer
working on neural networks now
what's consciousness what the hell is
that thing is that is that just some
little weird quirk of our particular uh
computing device
or is it something fundamental that we
really need to crack open if we're to
to build like good computers do you ever
think about consciousness like
why it feels like something to be i know
it's it's it's really weird
so yeah i mean
everything about it is weird first it's
a half a second behind reality
right it's a post-hoc narrative about
what happened you've already
done stuff by the time you're conscious
of it
and your consciousness generally is a
single threaded thing but we know your
brain is 10 billion neurons
running some crazy parallel thing
and there's a really big sorting thing
going on there
it also seems to be really reflective in
the sense that
you create a space in your head right
like we don't really see anything right
like
photons hit your eyes it gets turned
into signals it goes through multiple
layers the neurons
you know like i'm so curious that you
know that looks glassy and that looks
not glassy like
like how the resolution of your vision
is so high you have to go through all
this processing
yeah where for most of it it looks
nothing like vision
okay like like there's no theater in
your mind
right so we we have a world in our heads
we're literally just isolated behind our
sensors
but we can look at it speculate about it
speculate about alternatives problem
solve what if you know there's so many
things going on
and that process is lagging reality
and it's single threaded even though the
underlying thing is like
massively parallel so it's so curious
so imagine you're building an ai
computer if you wanted to replicate
humans well you'd have huge arrays of
neural networks and
apparently only six or seven deep which
clarious
they only remember seven numbers but i
think we can upgrade that a lot
right and then somewhere in there you
would train the network to create
basically
the world that you live in right so like
tell
stories to itself about the world that
it's perceiving well
create this create the world tell
stories in the world
and then have many dimensions of
you know like sideshows to it like we
have an emotional structure
like we have a biological structure and
that seems hierarchical too
like like if you're hungry it dominates
your thinking if you're mad it dominates
your thinking
like and we don't know if that's
important to consciousness or not but it
certainly
disrupts you know in truths in the
consciousness
like so there's lots of structure to
that and we like to dwell on the past we
like to think about the future we like
to imagine
we'd like to fantasize right and
the somewhat circular observation of
that is the thing
we call consciousness now if you created
a computer system it did all things
create world views created future
alternate histories
you know dwelled on past events you know
accurately or semi-accurately
you know it's it's consciousness just
bring up like
natural well would that feel look and
feel conscious to you like do you think
do you think the thing that looks
conscious is conscious like
do you uh again this is like an
engineering kind of question i think
because
uh like
if we want to engineer consciousness is
it okay to engineer something that just
looks conscious
or is it is there a difference between
well we have all consciousness because
it's a super effective way to manage our
affairs
yeah it's right the social development
yeah well it gives us the planning
system
you know we have a huge amount of stuff
like when we're talking
like the reason we can talk really fast
is we're modeling each other a really
high level of detail and consciousness
is required for that right and
well all those components together
manifest consciousness
right so if we make intelligent beings
that we want to interact with that we're
like
you know wondering what they're thinking
you know you know looking forward to
seeing them
you know when they interact with them
they they're interesting surprising
you know fascinating you know they will
probably
feel conscious like we do and we'll
we'll perceive them as conscious
i don't know why not but you never know
another fun question on this because
in in from a computing perspective we're
trying to create something that's
human-like or superhuman-like
let me ask you about aliens aliens
uh do you think there's intelligent
alien civilizations out there and do you
think
their technology their computing
their ai bots their uh their chips
are of the same nature as ours
yeah i got i have no idea i mean if
there's lots of aliens out there they've
been awfully quiet
you know there's there's speculation
about why
there seems to be more than enough
planets
out there there's a lot yeah um
there's intelligent life on this planet
that seems quite different you know like
you know dolphins seem like plausibly
understandable octopuses don't seem
understandable at all
if they live longer than a year maybe
they would be running the planet
they seem really smart and their neural
architecture is completely different
than ours
now who knows how they perceive things i
mean that's the question is for us
intelligent beings who might not be able
to perceive other kinds of intelligence
if they become sufficiently different
than us so yeah
we live in the current constrained world
that you know it's three-dimensional
geometry and
the geometry defines a certain amount of
physics
and you know you know there's like how
time works seems to work
like there's so many things that seem
like a whole bunch of the input
parameters to the you know another
conscious being are the same
yes like if it's biological biological
things seem to be in a relatively narrow
temperature range
right because you know organic stones
aren't stable too cold or too hot
you know so so there's if you specified
the list of things that
input to that but as soon as we make
really smart
you know beings and they go solve about
how to think about a billion numbers at
the same time and
and how to think in n there's a funny
science fiction book where the all the
society
had uploaded into this matrix and at
some point some some of the beans in the
matrix
thought i wonder if there's intelligent
life out there
so they had to do a whole bunch of work
to figure out like how to make a
physical thing
because their matrix was self-sustaining
and they made a little spaceship and
they traveled to another planet when
they got there
there was like life running around but
there was no intelligent life
and then they figured out that there was
these huge
you know organic matrix all over the
planet inside there where intelligent
beings had uploaded themselves
into that matrix so everywhere
intelligent life was as soon as it got
smart
it up leveled itself into something way
more interesting than 3d geometry and
yeah it escaped whatever this is not
escaped
better yeah the the essence of what we
think of as an intelligent being
i tend to like the thought experiment of
the organism like humans aren't the
organisms
i like the notion of like richard
dawkins and memes
that ideas themselves are the organisms
like that are just using our minds to
evolve
so like we're just like meat receptacles
for ideas to breed and multiply and so
on and
maybe those are the aliens yes so
uh jordan peterson has a line says you
know you think you have ideas but ideas
have you
yeah right good line which and and then
we know about the phenomena of
groupthink
and there's so many things that
constrain us
but i think you can examine all that and
not be
completely owned by the ideas and
completely sucked into groupthink
and part of your responsibility as a as
a human
is to escape that kind of phenomena
which isn't you know it's
you know it's it's one of the creative
tension things again you're constructed
by it
but you can still observe it and you can
think about it and you can make choices
about
to some level how constrained you are by
it
and you know it's useful to do that
and but but at the same time
and it could be by doing that that you
know the the the group and society
you're
you're part of becomes collectively even
more interesting
so you know so the outside observer will
think wow
you know all these lexus running around
with all these really independent ideas
have created something even more
interesting
and uh aggregate so
so i uh so i don't know i'm those are
lenses to look at the situation
but i'll give you some inspiration but i
don't think they're constrained
right you know as a small little quirk
of history
it seems like you're related to jordan
peterson
like you mentioned he's going through
some rough stuff now
is there some comment you can make about
the the roughness of the human journey
the ups and downs well
i i became an expert in benzo withdrawal
like which is you took benzodiazepines
and at some point
they interact with gaba circuits
you know to reduce anxiety and do 100
other things like there's actually
no known list of everything they do
because they interact with so many parts
of your body
and then once you're on them you
habituate to them and you're you're
you have a dependency it's not like
you're a drug dependency we're trying to
get high it's a
it's a metabolic dependency and then if
you
discontinue them there's a funny thing
called
kindling which is if you stop them
and then go you know you'll have a
horrible it's for all symptoms if you go
back on them at the same level you won't
be stable
and that unfortunately happened to him
because it's so deeply integrated into
all the kinds of systems in the body it
literally changes the size and numbers
of
neurotransmitter sites in your brain
yeah so there's a there's a
process called the ashton protocol where
you taper it down
slowly over two years to people go
through that goes through unbelievable
hell
and what jordan went through seemed to
be worse because
the on advice of doctors you know we'll
stop taking these and take this
it was the disaster and he got some
yeah it was pretty tough um he seems to
be doing
quite a bit better intellectually you
can see his brain clicking back together
i spent a lot of time with i've never
seen anybody suffer so much well his
brain is also like this
powerhouse right so i wonder does a
brain
that's able to think deeply about the
world suffer more through these kinds of
withdrawals like
i don't know i've watched videos of
people going through withdrawal
they they all seem to suffer
unbelievably
and you know my work goes out to
everybody
and there's some funny math about this
some doctors said as best you can tell
you know there's the standard
recommendations don't take them for more
than a month and then taper over a
couple of weeks
many doctors prescribe them endlessly
which is against the protocol but
it's common right and then
something like 75 percent of people when
they taper
it's you know half the people have
difficulty but 75
get off okay 20 have severe difficulty
and 5
have life-threatening difficulty and if
you're one of those it's really bad
and the stories that people have on this
is
heartbreaking and tough so you put some
of the fault that the doctors that just
not know what the hell they're doing
oh no it's hard to say it's it's one of
those commonly prescribed things like
one doctor said what happens is if
you're prescribed them for a reason
and then you have a hard time getting
off the protocol basically says you're
either crazy or dependent
and you get kind of pushed into a
different treatment regime
you're a drug drug addict or a
psychiatric patient
and so like one doctor said you know i
prescribed me for 10 years thinking i
was helping my patients and i realized i
was really harming them
and you know the awareness of that is
slowly coming up
the fact that they're casually
prescribed
to people is horrible
and it's bloody scary and some people
are stable on them but they're on them
for life
like once you know it's another one of
those drugs that
but benzo's long range have real impacts
on your personality
people talk about the benzo bubble where
you get disassociated from reality and
your friends a little bit
it's it's it's it's really terrible the
mind is terrifying we were talking about
how
how the infinite possibility of fun but
like
it's the infinite possibility of
suffering too which is one of the
dangers of
uh like expansion of the human mind it's
like
i wonder if all the possible huma
experiences that a
intelligent computer can have is it
mostly fun or is it mostly
suffering so like if you if you uh brute
force expand
the set of possibilities like are you
going to run into some trouble
in terms of like torture and suffering
and so on maybe our human brain is just
protecting us from much more possible
pain and suffering
maybe the space of pain is like much
larger than we could possibly imagine
and that the world's in the balance
you know all the all the literature on
religion and stuff is
you know the struggle between good and
evil is is balanced versus
very finely tuned for reasons that are
complicated
but that's a that's a long philosophical
conversation
uh speaking of balance that's
complicated i i wonder because we're
living through one of the more important
moments in human history with this
particular virus
it seems like pandemics have at least
the ability to
uh kill off most of the human population
at their worst and they're just
fascinating because there's so many
viruses in this world
there's so many i mean viruses basically
around the world in the sense that uh
they've been around very long time
they're everywhere
they seem to be extremely powerful and
they're just in a distributed kind of
way but
at the same time they're not intelligent
and they're not even living
do you have like high level thoughts
about this virus that uh
like in terms of you being fascinated
about terrified or
not somewhere in between so i believe in
frameworks right
so like one of them is the evolution
like we're evolved creatures right yes
and
one of the things about evolution is
it's hyper competitive
and it's not competitive out of a sense
of evil it's competitive in the sense of
there's endless variation in variations
that work better when
and then over time there's so many
levels of that competition
you know like multi-cellular life partly
exists because
of you know the the competition between
you know different kinds of life forms
and we know sex partly exists to
scramble our genes so that we have
you know genetic variation against
the invasion of the bacteria and the
viruses and it's endless like
i read some funny statistic like the
density of viruses and bacteria in the
ocean
is really high and one third of the
bacteria die every day because the virus
is invading them
like one-third of them wow like
like i don't know if that number is true
but it was like it's
like there's like the amount of
competition and what's going on is
stunning
and there's a theory as we age we slowly
accumulate bacterias and viruses
and as our immune system kind of goes
down
you know that's what slowly kills us and
it just feels so peaceful from a human
perspective when we sit back and they're
able to have a relaxed conversation
uh and there's wars going on out there
like right now
you're you're harboring how many
bacteria and you know the ones
many of them are parasites on you and
some of them are helpful and some of
them are modifying your behavior and
some of them are
you know it's just really it's really
wild but
you know this particular manifestation
is unusual
you know in the demographic how it hit
and the political
you know response that it engendered and
you know the health care
response it engendered and the
technology it's gendered it's kind of
wild
yeah the communication on twitter that
it uh every level all that kind of stuff
at every single level yeah
but but what usually kills life the big
extinctions are caused by
meteors and volcanoes that's the one
you're worried about as opposed to
human-created bombs solar flares are
another good one
you know occasionally solar flares hit
the planet so it's nature
oh yes yeah it's all pretty wild on
another historic moment
this is perhaps outside but perhaps
within your uh
space of frameworks that you think about
that just happened
i guess a couple weeks ago is um i don't
know if you're paying attention at all
it's the
the game stop and wall street bets
so it's really fascinating there's kind
of a theme to this conversation
today because it's like you know that
works the
it's cool how there's a large number of
people in a distributed way
almost having a kind of fun we're able
to take on
the powerful elites elite hedge funds
centralized powers and overpower them
uh do you have thoughts i mean saga
i don't know enough about finance but it
was like the elon
you know robin hood guy when they talked
yeah what do you think about that
well the robin guy didn't know how the
finance system worked that was clear
right he was treating like the the
people who settled the transactions as a
black box
and suddenly somebody called him up and
said hey black box calling you
your transaction volume means you need
to put up three billion dollars right
now and he's like i don't have three
billion dollars
like i don't even make any money on
these trades why do i owe three billion
dollars while you're sponsoring the
trade
so so there was a set of abstractions
that
you know i don't think either like like
now he understands it like
this happens in chip design like you buy
wafers from tsmc or samsung or intel
and you know they say it works like this
and you do your design based on that and
then chip comes back and doesn't work
and then suddenly you start having to
open the black boxes like the
transistors really work like they said
you know what's the real issue
so so the
there's a whole set of things that
created this opportunity and somebody
spotted it
now people spot these kinds of
opportunities all the times there's been
flash crashes there's been
you know there's always short squeezes
are fairly regular every ceo i know
hates the shorts because they're they're
manipulating
they're trying to manipulate their stock
in a way that they make money
and you know deprive value from both
this you know the company and the
investors
so the fact that
you know some of these stocks were so
short it's hilarious
that this hasn't happened before i don't
know why and i don't actually know why
some serious hedge funds didn't do it to
other hedge funds
and some of the hedge funds actually
made a lot of money on this yes
so my my guess is we know
five percent of what really happened and
that a lot of the players don't know
what happened
and the people who probably made the
most money aren't the people that
they're talking about
yeah that's do you think there was
something uh
i mean this is the this is the cool kind
of uh
elon uh you're the same kind of
conversationalist which is like first
principles
questions of like what the hell happened
uh just very basic questions of like was
there something shady going on
uh what you know who are the parties
involved it's the basic questions that
everybody wants to know about
yeah so like we're in a very hyper
competitive world right
but transactions like buying and selling
stock is a trust event
you know i trust the company
representing themselves properly you
know
i bought the stock because i think it's
going to go up i trust that the
regulations are solid
now inside of that there's all kinds of
places where
you know humans over trust and
you know this this expose let's say some
weak points in the system
i don't know if it's going to get
corrected i don't know if the
i don't know if we have close to the
real story
yeah my suspicion is we don't yeah and
listen to that guy he was
like a little wide-eyed about and then
he did this and then they did that and
it was like
i think you should know more about that
your business than that
but again there's many businesses when
like this layer is really stable
you stop paying attention to it you pay
attention to the stuff that's bugging
you
or new you don't pay attention to the
stuff that just seems to work all the
time you just
you know the sky's blue every day
california and where once a while the
continued rains there was like what do
we do
somebody go bring in the lawn furniture
you know like it's getting wet
we don't know it's getting wet yeah it
doesn't it was blue for like 100 days
and now it's
you know so but part of the problem here
with vlad this
the ceo of robin hood is the scaling is
that what we've been talking about is
there's a lot of unexpected things that
happen with the scaling
and you have to be i think the scaling
forces you to then return to the
fundamentals
well it's interesting because when you
buy and sell stocks the scaling is you
know the stocks only move in a certain
range and if you buy a stock you can
only lose that amount of money
on the short short market you can lose a
lot more than you can
benefit like it has a it has a weird
cost you know cost function or whatever
the right word for that is
so he was trading in a market where he
wasn't actually capitalized for the
downside
if it got outside a certain range
now whether something the various has
happened i have no idea
but at some point the
financial risk to both him and his
customers was way outside of his
financial capacity
and his understanding how the system
work was clearly
weak or or he didn't represent himself i
you know i don't know the person
when i listened to him nick yeah it
could have been the surprise question
was like and then these guys called and
you know it sounded like he was treating
stuff as a black box
maybe he shouldn't have but maybe his
whole pilot expert somewhere else and it
was going on i don't i don't know
yep i mean this is uh this is one of the
qualities of
a good leader is under fire you have to
perform
and that means to think clearly and to
speak clearly
and he dropped the ball on those things
because
and understand the problem quickly learn
and understand the problem
like at this like basic level
like what the hell happened and my guess
is
you know at some level it was amateurs
trading against
you know expert slash insiders slash
people with you know special information
outsiders is insiders yeah and the
insiders
you know my guess is the next time this
happens we'll make money on it
the insiders always win well they have
more
tools and more incentive i mean this
always happens like the outsiders are
doing this for fun the insiders are
doing this 24 7.
but there's numbers in the outsiders
this is the interesting thing
well there's numbers on the insiders too
like different kind of numbers different
kind of numbers
but this could be a new era because i
don't know at least i didn't expect that
uh a bunch of redditors could
you know there's uh you know millions of
people who can get together
the next one won't be a surprise but
don't you think the
the the crowd the people are planning
the next attack
we'll see but it has to be a surprise
can't be the same game
as to the end it could be there's a very
large number of games to play and they
can be
agile about it i don't know i'm not an
expert right that's a good question how
the space of games how how restricted is
it
yeah and the system is so complicated it
could be relatively unrestricted
and also like you know during the last
couple financial crashes
you know what set it off was you know
sets of derivative events where
you know the you know nasim talibs you
know thing is
they're they're they're trying to lower
volatility
in the short run but creating tail
events and
systems always evolve towards that and
then they always crash like
the gas curve is the you know star low
ramp plateau crash it's 100
effective in the long run
let me ask you some advice to put on
your profound hat
what uh there's a bunch of young folks
to listen to this thing
for no good reason whatsoever
undergraduate students maybe high school
students maybe just young folks a young
at heart
looking for the next steps to taking
life what advice would you give to a
young person today about
life maybe career but also life in
general
get good at some stuff well get to know
yourself right
get good at something that you're
actually interested in you have to love
what you're doing to get good at it
you really got to find that don't waste
all your time doing stuff that's just
boring or bland or numbing
right don't let old people screw you
well people get talked into doing all
kinds of [ __ ] and wrapping up huge
student
you know student debts and like there's
so much crap going on
you know and then it drains your time
and drains yeah the eric weinstein you
know
thesis that you know the older
generation will let go
yeah and they're trapping all the young
people i think there's some truth to
that
yeah sure just because you're old
doesn't mean you stop thinking i know
lots of really original
yeah old people i'm an old person
so um but you have to be conscious about
it you can fall into the ruts and then
do that you know when i hear young
people spouting opinions that sounds
like they come from fox news or cnn i
think they've been captured by
groupthink and memes and supposed to
think on their own
you know so if you find yourself
repeating what everybody else is saying
you're not going to have a good life
like like that's not how the world works
it may be
it seems safe but it puts you at great
jeopardy for
well being boring or unhappy or
how long did it take you to find the
thing that uh
you have fun with well i don't know
i've been a fun person since i was
pretty little so everything i've gone
through a couple periods of depression
in my life
for a good reason or for uh the reason
that doesn't make any sense
yeah like some some things are hard
like you go through mental transitions
in high school i was
really depressed for a year and i think
i had my first midlife crisis at 26.
i kind of thought is this all there is
like i was working at a job that i loved
and but i was going to work and all my
time is consumed
what's what's the escape out of that
depression what's the answer to is
is this all there is well
a friend of mine i asked him because he
was working his ass off i said what's
your work-life balance
like like there's you know work friends
family
personal time are you bouncing in that
and he said work 80
family 20 and i try to i try to find
some time to sleep
like there's no personal time there's no
passion at a time
because you know young people are often
passionate about work so and i was
certainly like that
but you need to you need to have some
space in your life for different things
and that's that creates uh that makes
you resistant to the whole
the the the dip the the deep dips into
depression kind of thing yeah well you
have to get to know yourself too
meditation helps some physical
something physically intense helps like
the weird places your mind goes kind of
thing
like and why does it happen why do you
do what you do like triggers like
the things that cause your mind to go to
different places kind of thing or
events like you're upbringing for better
or worse whether your parents are great
people or not
you you you come into
you know adulthood with all kinds of
emotional burdens
yeah and you can see some people are so
bloody stiff and restrained and they
think you know the world's fundamentally
negative
like you maybe you have unexplored
territory
yeah or you're afraid of something uh
definitely afraid of quite a few things
then you gotta go face them like like
what's the worst thing that happened
you're going to die right
like that's inevitable you might as well
get over that like a 100
death rate like people were worried
about the virus but
you know the human condition is pretty
deadly
there's something about embarrassment
let's see i've competed a lot in my life
and i think the if i'm too introspected
the thing i'm most afraid of is
being like humiliated i think nobody
cares about that
look you're the only person on the
planet zack cares about you being
humiliated exactly
it's like a really useless thought it is
it's like uh you're all humiliating
something happened in a room full of
people and they walk out and they didn't
think about it one more second
or maybe somebody told a funny story to
somebody else and then it just hates it
throughout yeah
yeah now i know it too i mean
i've been really embarrassed about [ __ ]
that nobody cared about myself
yeah it's a funny thing so the worst
thing ultimately is just
uh yeah but that's the cage and then you
have to get out of it yeah
like once you here's the thing once you
find something like that
you have to be determined to break it
because otherwise you'll just you know
slowly accumulate that kind of junk and
then you die as a
you know a mess so the goal i guess it's
so
it's like a cage with a cage i guess the
goal is to die in the biggest possible
cage
well ideally you have no cage
people do get enlightened i've got a few
it's great you found a few there's a few
out there i don't know of course
um either that or they have you know
it's a great sales pitch there's like
enlightened people writing books and
doing all kinds of stuff
it's a good way to sell a book i'll give
you that you've never met somebody you
just thought
they just killed me like this like like
mental clarity humor no 100 but i just
feel like they're living in a bigger
cage they have their own
they don't think there's a cage they're
still okay you secretly suspect there's
always the case
ah there's no there's nothing outside
the the unit there's nothing outside the
cage
[Laughter]
you were you worked in a bunch of
companies
uh you led a lot of amazing teams
um i don't i'm not sure if you've ever
been like at the early stages of a
startup
but do you have advice for
uh somebody that wants to uh do a
startup or build a company
like build a strong team of engineers
that are passionate just want to
uh solve a big problem like is there uh
more specifically on that point well you
have to be really good at stuff
if you're going to lead and build a team
you better be really interested in how
people work and think
the people or the solution to the
problems there's two things right
one is how people work and the other is
actually
there's there's quite a few successful
startups it's pretty clear the founders
don't know anything about people
like the idea was so powerful that it
propelled them
but i suspect somewhere early they they
hired some people who understood people
because people really need a lot of care
and feeding to collaborate and work
together and
feel engaged and work hard you know like
startups are
all about out producing other people
like you're nimble because you don't
have any legacy
you don't have you know a bunch of
people who are depressed about life
you know just showing up you know so
startups have a lot of advantages that
way
you know do you like the the steve jobs
talked about this idea
of a players and b players i don't know
if you uh
know this formulation yeah no um
organizations that get taken over by pb
player leaders
often really underperform their rc
players
that said in big organizations there's
so much work to do
like and there's so many people who are
happy to do what you know like the
leadership or the
big idea people who can see it consider
menial jobs
and you know you need a place for them
but you need an organization that
both values and rewards them but doesn't
let them take over the leadership of it
got it but so so you need to have an
organization that's resistant to that
but
in the early days the the notion with
with steve was that like one b player in
a room
of a players will be like destructive to
the whole
i've seen that happen i i don't know if
it's like always true
like you know you you run into people
who are clearly b players but they think
they're very players and so they have a
loud voice at the table and they make
lots of demands for that
but there's other people are like i know
who i am i just want to work with you
know cool people and cool [ __ ] and just
tell me what to do and i'll go get it
done
yeah you know so you have to again this
is like people skills like
what kind of person is it you know i've
met some really great
people i love working with that weren't
the biggest id people the most
productive ever but they show up they
get it done
you know they create connection and
community that people
value it's it's it's pretty diverse so i
don't think there's a recipe for that
i gotta ask you about love i heard
you're into this now
into this love thing yeah is this is you
think this is your solution to your
depression
no i'm just trying to like you said the
enlightened people on occasion trying to
sell a book i'm writing a book about
love you're writing a book about me no
i'm not i'm not
a friend of mine he's gonna
somebody said you should really write a
book about your you know your management
philosophy he said it'd be a short book
[Laughter]
well that one was all pretty well uh
what role do you think
love family friendship all that kind of
uh
human stuff play in a successful life
you've been exceptionally successful in
the space of
like running teams building cool [ __ ] in
this world
creating some amazing things what uh did
love get in the way did love help
the family get in the way to family help
friendship you want the engineer's
answer
please so but first love is functional
right
it's functional in what way so we
habituate ourselves to the environment
and actually jordan told me jordan
peterson told me this line
so you go through life and you just get
used to everything except for the things
you love
they they remain new like this is really
useful for you know
like like other people's children and
dogs and you know trees
you just don't pay that much attention
to your own kids you monitor them really
closely
like and if they go off a little bit
because you love them if you're smart
if you're going to be a successful
parent you notice it right away
you don't habituate to
just things you love and if you want to
be successful at work if you don't love
it
you're not going to put the time in
somebody else it's somebody else that
loves it like
because it's new and interesting and
that lets you go to the next level
so it's the thing it's just a function
that generates newness
and novelty and surprises you know those
kind of things
it's really interesting but and there's
people figured out lots of
you know frameworks for this you know
like like humans seem to go in
partnership go through
you know interest like somebody suddenly
somebody's interesting
and then you're infatuated with them and
then you're in love with them
and then you you know different people
have ideas about parental love or mature
love like you go through a cycle of that
which keeps us together and it's you
know super functional for creating
families and
and creating communities and making you
support somebody despite the fact that
you don't love them
like and and
it can be really enriching you know
now in the work life balance scheme if
all you do is work
you think you may be optimizing your
work potential but if you don't
love your work or you don't have family
and friends and things you care about
your brain isn't well balanced like
everybody knows the experience of you
works on something all week you went
home and took two days off and you came
back in
the odds of you working on the thing you
picking up right where you left off is
zero
your brain refactored it
but being in blood is great it's like
changes the color of the light in the
room
it creates a spaciousness that's that's
different it helps you think
it makes you strong buckowski had this
line about
love being a fog that dissipates with
the first light of reality
in the morning it's that's depressing i
think it's the other way around
it lasts well you like you said it's a
function it's a thing that just
be the light that actually enlivens your
world and
creates the interest and the power and
the strength and the
to go do something well it's like
like that sounds like you know there's
like physical love emotional of
intellectual love spiritually yeah
right isn't it all the same thing kind
of nope
you should differentiate that maybe
that's your problem in your book you
should you should refine that a little
bit
different chapters yeah there's
different chapters what's that what's
these are there aren't these are just
different layers of the same thing
the stack no physical people people
some people are addicted to physical
love and they have no idea about
emotional or intellectual love
i don't know if they're the same thing
so i think they're different that's true
they could be different it'd be
it i guess the ultimate goal is for it
to be the same well if you want
something to be bigger and interesting
you should find
all its components and differentiate
them not climb it together
people do this all the time they yeah
and the modularity
get your abstraction layers right and
then you can you have room to breathe
well maybe you can write the forward to
my book about love
yeah or the afterwards and the after you
really tried
i feel like lex has made a lot of
progress in this book but
uh well you have things in your life
that you love yeah
yeah you know so and they are you're
right they're modular it's
and you can have multiple things with
the same person or the same
thing and yeah but yeah
depending on the moment of the day yeah
there's like what bukowski
described as that moment you go from
being in love to having
a different kind of love yeah right and
that's the transition
but when it happens if you read the
owner's manual and you believed it
you would have said oh this happened it
doesn't mean it's not love it's a
different kind of love
but but maybe there's something better
about
that as you grow old if all you do is
regret
how you used to be it's sad right
you should have learned a lot of things
because like who you can be in your
future self is
is actually more interesting and
possibly delightful than
you know being a mad kid in love with
the
the next person like that's super fun
when it happens but
that's that's you know five percent of
the possibility
yeah that's right that there's a lot
more fun to be had in the long lasting
stuff
yeah or meaning you know if that's me
which is a kind of fun
it's a deeper kind of fun and it's
surprising you know that's
like like the thing i like is surprises
you know and you just never know what's
gonna happen yeah
but you have to look carefully and you
have to work at it you have to think
about it and
you know it's yeah you have to see the
surprises when they happen
right you have to be looking for it from
the branching perspective
you mentioned regrets uh
do you have regrets about your own
trajectory oh yeah of course
yeah some of it's painful but you want
to hear the painful stuff
i'd say like in terms of working with
people
when people did say stuff i didn't like
especially if it was a bit nefarious
i took it personally and i also felt it
was personal about them but a lot of
times
like humans are you know most humans are
a mess right and then they act out and
they do stuff
and i this psychologist i heard a long
time ago said
you tend to think somebody does
something to you
but really what they're doing is they're
doing what they're doing while they're
in front of you
it's not that much about you yeah right
and
as i got more interested in
you know when i work with people i think
about them and
probably analyze them and understand
them a little bit and then when they do
stuff i'm way less surprised and i'm
wait you know and if it's bad i'm way
less
hurt and i react way less like i sort of
expect
everybody's got their [ __ ] yeah and it's
not about you
it's not about me that much it's like
you know
you know you do something and you think
you're embarrassed but nobody cares
like and somebody's really mad at you at
the odds of it being about
you yeah no they're getting mad the way
they're doing that because of some
pattern they learned
and you know and maybe you can help them
if you care enough about it
but or you could step you could see it
coming and step out of the way
like like i wish i was way better at
that i'm i'm a bit of a hothead
and and you said with steve that was a
feature not a bug
yeah well he was using it as the counter
force the orderliness that would crush
his work well you were doing the same
yeah maybe i don't think i don't think
my uh my vision was big enough
it was more like i just got pissed off
and did stuff
i'm sure that's just yeah yeah you're
telling me
i don't know if it had the it didn't
have the amazing effect of creating the
trillion dollar company it was more like
i just got pissed off and left
and or made enemies that he shouldn't
have been
yeah it's hard like i didn't really
understand politics until i worked at
apple
where you know steve was a master player
of politics and his staff had to be or
they wouldn't survive them and
it was definitely part of the culture
and then i've been in companies where
they say it's political but it's all
you know fun and games compared to apple
and it's not that
the people apple are bad people it's
just they operated politically at a
higher level
you know it's not like oh somebody said
something bad about somebody
somebody else which is most politics
it's
you know they they had strategies about
accomplishing their goals
sometimes you know over the dead bodies
of their enemies
you know with some communication yeah
more game of thrones and sophistication
and like a big time factor rather than a
you know well that requires a lot of
control over your emotions i think
uh to do to have a bigger strategy in
the way you behave
yeah and it's it's it's effective in the
sense that coordinating thousands of
people to do really hard things
where many of the people in there don't
understand themselves much less how
they're participating
yeah creates all kinds of
you know drama and problems that you
know our solution is political in nature
like how do you convince people how do
you leverage them how do you motivate
them how do you get rid of them how you
know like there's
there's so many layers of that that are
interesting
and even though some some of it let's
say may be tough
it's not evil
unless you know you use that skill to
evil purposes which some people
obviously do but
but it's a skill set that operates you
know and i wish i'd
you know i was interested in it but i
you know it was sort of like i'm an
engineer i do my thing
and you know there's there's times when
i could have way bigger
impact if i you know knew how to
if i paid more attention and knew more
about that
about the human layer of the stack yeah
that human
political power you know expression
layer of the stack
which is complicated and there's lots to
know about it i mean people are good at
it are just amazing
and when they're good at it and let's
say
relatively kind and oriented in a good
direction
you can really feel it can get lots of
stuff done and coordinate things you
never thought possible
but all people like that also have some
pretty hard edges because
you know it's it's a heavy lift and i
wish i'd spent more time with that when
i was younger but
but maybe i wasn't ready you know i was
a wide-eyed kid for 30 years
it's a little bit of a kid i know what
do you
hope your legacy is when there's a
when there's a book like a hitchhiker's
guide to the galaxy and this is like a
one sentence entry ball jim caller from
like that guy lived at some point
there's not many you know not many
people be remembered uh you're one of
the
sparkling little human creatures
that had a big impact on the world how
do you hold you'll be remembered
my daughter was trying to get uh she
added my wikipedia page to say that i
was a legend and a guru
but they took it out so she put it back
in she's 15.
i think i think that was probably the
best part of my legacy
[Laughter]
she got her sister they were all excited
they were like trying to put it in the
references because there's articles in
that and
they're telling you that so the eyes of
your kids your
uh legend well they're pretty skeptical
because they'll be better than that
they're like dad so yeah that's
that's stupid that kind of stuff is
super fun in terms of the big legends
stuff anchor
okay legacy i don't really care you're
just an engineer
no they've been thinking about building
a big pyramid
so i had a debate with a friend about
whether pyramids or craters are cooler
and you realize that there's craters
everywhere but you know they built a
couple of pyramids five thousand years
ago in there
and they remember you think that would
be
foreign
uh those aren't easy to build oh i know
and they don't actually know how they
built them which is great
it's either uh agi or aliens could be
involved so i think
i think you're gonna have to figure out
quite a few more things than just
the basics of civil engineering
so i guess you hope your legacy is
pyramids
that would that would be cool and my
wikipedia page you know getting updated
by my daughter periodically
like those two things would pretty much
make it jim it's a huge honor talking to
you again i hope we talk many more times
in the future
i can't wait to see what you do with
tennis torrent
i can't wait to use it i can't wait for
you to revolutionize
yet another space in computing
it's a huge honor to talk to you thanks
for talking today this was fun
thanks for listening to this
conversation with jim keller and thank
you to our sponsors athletic greens
all-in-one nutrition drink brooklyn and
sheetz
expressvpn and bel campbell grass-fed
meat
click the sponsor links to get a
discount and to support this podcast
and now let me leave you with some words
from alan turing
those who can imagine anything can
create
the impossible thank you for listening
and hope to see you
next time
you